The Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast.
Hello everybody.
Hello,
Philip DEFRANCO.
You're
welcome.
I don't know what that voice saw.
Bob,
welcome to the show though.
Yeah,
it's just a fun day because this is the first day of.
You're listening to this in the future.
This is the day after the Seth Rogen James Franco movie got pulled from all
theaters because of anonymous threats from some hacker characters,
which is a pretty fucking weird,
Huh?
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's rough sucker right up,
right up on my mouth.
That's what I like to say.
Living inside you.
It's A.
I mean it's,
it is rough.
There were a lot of.
I saw a lot of people reacting yesterday like,
I can't believe America did this.
And I was like,
it's Sony is not in America.
They actually Japanese.
It's kind of Hilarious,
but yeah,
it is weird,
right?
Because I mean it does.
I mean it sets this like this precedent that if you make something that we might
not want,
we can pressure you away from me.
Actually releasing it.
A defector says that North Korea has 1800 cyber warriors.
What does that mean?
That means he has a whole clone of people that will attack anybody that a clone.
I mean group of clubs.
The whole army army say,
yeah,
what the fuck man.
Yeah,
and it's weird,
right?
Because every time you see like a picture of North Korea and like a person in
front of a computer,
it looks like they're just trying to figure out how to use it.
They're like,
what is this?
Well,
obviously South Korea is responsible for Samsung and you know,
so many incredible innovations come out of South Korea.
I mean they,
they make some of the best electronics in the world.
So I got to think that some of that smarts gets up into North Korea.
It's going through that minefield.
It's able to get there.
I would imagine the state steal people and are something.
They just hire him.
They just throw money at him.
Probably nobody's from South Korea is going to go to North Korea because they'll
keep you there.
They'll do whatever the fuck they want.
I mean,
you hear that shit that they do to those people in North Korea.
It's like the last,
at all,
those historical dictatorships that you,
you heard about like all throughout time where people did horrific,
terrible things to the people that,
you know,
they were,
there were under the people that were under their mother.
This is like the last one of those,
the last one that was a real dictatorship,
like one guy who really runs the whole show and everyone's terrified.
Yeah.
And I thought there was like the thought that he was actually going to be
knocked out of power and then it just turned out he had a cold and he sprained
his ankle.
Yeah.
Who knows,
who knows what's going on over there.
But as a person who,
you do these youtube videos and you started them essentially,
did
you just sit in front of a camera and just create your own?
Just.
Yeah,
I mean I was,
uh,
it was eight years ago.
Uh,
I was in,
I was in college,
uh,
I was going through the premed program.
I hated life and I had no money.
So Youtube was just like this free entertainment because I couldn't go out and
do anything.
And so I was watching these videos and even to this day I think like when people
watch me,
it's like,
what is this schmuck talking about?
I could do this and I could probably do it better.
And so that's what I felt eight years ago and I just kinda started ranting about
bill o'reilly and then that turned into more pop culture.
And then it turned into like the eight minute show.
That thing that you did recently,
this is one that really got me,
is that Lena Dunham thing,
which,
which one?
I know they've talked about it a few times.
Did you talk about a few times,
the one where you were,
you,
you danced around it very well for folks who don't know the story,
Lena Dunham wrote a book and in the book she described this sexual encounter
that she had with a man where,
um,
it's tough to say exactly what was going on,
but her description of it was essentially that the guy was being very,
uh,
forward or,
you know,
very,
very pushy.
And she started talking dirty to him out of.
I don't know how she described that she just was out of fear.
Is that what she said or.
I'm trying to think of that specific one.
I know that I feel like one of the last time she was in it,
there were people that were accusing her of molesting
her sister.
Yes.
That's a different one.
Okay.
So definitely think that when you're talking about.
This is the one where she.
She was saying that the guy raped her,
but she was talking dirty to the guy.
I don't think I covered that one.
Yeah,
you did.
I did say yeah,
you definitely question while you were just saying that it was some mixed
signals that she was sending these crazy mixed signals that it confuses people
as to what the definition,
the actual definition of rape.
Like what this,
this.
We're in a weird time now.
Okay.
And in this weird time that we're at,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot of exposure and a lot of discussion about rape and I think that's
a very good thing because obviously rape is it terrifying,
horrible crime.
I have three daughters,
you know,
it scares the shit out of me.
Um,
I just,
it just as a human being,
it's scares the shit out of me that someone can do that to someone.
But this description which she described in her book,
it doesn't sound like you could call that rape to me.
I mean,
it sounds like an unfortunate sexual encounter.
Her roommates convinced her after the fact that it was rape,
you know,
the whole story.
She was telling her,
I can't believe you don't remember what my videos.
I don't think I made this.
You must have.
No,
I mean,
it might've been sourced,
fed maybe.
No,
it was you dude.
Okay.
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna go after.
Do you find that you motherfucker.
Oh,
it's going to be that,
that got you moment.
I'll be like,
when did I make this video?
But either way,
um,
the,
the idea behind it is that she decided after the fact that somehow or another
this was,
this was rape and then she wrote this book about it.
And now the guy who,
you didn't talk about this,
but the guy who was the accused in this has now lawyered up and even though he's
under a different name,
people have sort of identified who he actually is and it's become this crazy
ugly thing.
And then it came out that she molested her 12 year old sister for like a lot of
years.
Many years.
Yeah.
I,
no,
there was the story that she wrote in the book and it was about her sister when
she was like one or two.
I think it was something like that.
And there was like the gravel story and I mean that was,
that was weird.
The way that I like to cover it is if it's not black and white,
which very few things are.
I try to talk about what both sides say and then like where my mental
place is at that moment.
Um,
but I mean there's a lot of conversation about,
about rape right now.
And I think I agree with you,
it is a,
it is very good.
Especially with all the bill bill cosby stuff.
Yeah.
This was what it was.
It was real rape versus rape culture.
How long ago was that?
I don't know.
What did you just Google Philly.
The rape because this is weird now.
I might,
I might be wrong.
Dude,
I might be wrong and it actually might have been somebody else into that video.
Sorry.
I was like,
oh no,
I haven't done.
Sorry.
You've done a few though,
right?
You've done a few on her in this whole story.
I've talked about her in the book.
I've talked about a rape stories recently just because it's.
There's just.
There is a real conversation to be had and so many times it just gets lost on
the Internet whether it's some stupid Hashtag that goes out there and had a good
intention and gets hijacked and then it becomes just men versus women rather
than all of us against.
Right.
Oh,
it was steven crowder.
That's who it was.
I got you.
I got you confused,
but yeah,
all of us versus rapists.
Yeah.
This what is going on,
like why is like rape such a hot topic right now?
Like do we go in cycles where things become like important things to talk about
for whatever reason?
Like right now,
obviously it's race.
Race is a huge one now because of Ferguson,
because of the guy that got killed in New York or Eric Gardener.
We go in these weird cycles like pop culture cycle.
Well,
I mean I think it's something hits and then it is always a mishmash of think of
is it a real issue and people know that they're going to get clicks.
You know,
it's just riding that wave.
I think a big part of it is riding that wave but also like it's a problem.
I think when I talk to people,
a lot of it is,
you know,
I understand that I don't have that,
that mindset because of whether people call it white privilege or just like my
specific specific way of being raised.
I don't have that outlook on life.
So I find it very interesting.
Yeah.
I,
I think especially now with,
uh,
with race,
with race and with a police brutality like this is probably,
this subject has been brought up more and not just obviously on youtube videos
but just all throughout social media over the last couple months that I can ever
remember,
like in my lifetime.
I'm trying to think of other times.
I don't know,
race mean don't you think with all this,
uh,
Eric Garner stuff and all the stuff that's going on right now with,
with,
with Ferguson and the police protest.
This is a strange time.
It is,
it's very strange time.
I um,
the,
the situation in New New York I think perplex me the most just because uh,
I've been always just for the longest time talking about body cams on cops and
it just like,
it has to be a thing.
But like everything else,
there's no one fix.
It's not like we throw cameras on and it's like,
oh,
racism stopped.
But I do believe that it is a good first step and I think then you do have to
punish officers that do not turn those on.
And I think that places that make it where you can punish someone for filming a
police officer if you into agonize the cop,
you know,
I think that's something.
But just filming,
like showing what happened.
Like that's crazy.
It's crazy.
And they just passed that recently in one of the states,
Illinois,
I think it was.
Yeah.
Chicago is just insane.
I mean,
I dunno what the fuck they're trying to accomplish by not having complete
transparency like that.
That's bizarre.
Right?
It just,
it,
you wonder like why.
I mean,
and there have been police officers that come out saying the only people that
would be against
this are dirty cops.
Yeah.
Or people that just don't want any more scrutiny.
Maybe they think that maybe they think there's like,
especially with Chicago,
Chicago is so bad and the gang violence in Chicago is so completely out of
control.
And you know,
you read about the murder rates in Chicago,
they're off the charts.
Maybe there's think the only way to clean that up is to just fight fire with
fire and just use dirty cop k tactics or something like some big summer
blockbuster movie where you're like,
yeah,
it is.
Okay.
Yeah,
like some Denzel Washington character from that.
What was the movie training day where it becomes,
um,
you know,
I don't know.
So you,
you,
you started just ranting about things on these youtube videos.
Where along the line did everybody on Youtube agree to do these smash cuts?
Like,
will you edit out all of the dead air in between everything you say,
you know,
that weird thing that you guys do?
Yeah.
The jump cut.
Yeah,
the jump cut.
I mean the jump cut was a thing before,
before I did anything.
I think the guy that popularized it was zay frank who works.
He's like one of the big guys over at buzzfeed now,
but I mean just any,
anytime online,
it's not for youtube.
It's very not a podcast in the sense of where we're sitting down and you can
take a moment to to,
to drink those seconds matter.
If I don't make you interested in 15 seconds,
you're out.
Isn't that crazy?
I mean it's very.
It's very add overtime.
A youtube video is the longer content,
longer content can live,
but it is.
It is kind of what you have to understand when you're making that content,
but isn't it like in that sense,
aren't you like kowtowing to morons?
You think someone who can't,
can't like pause
that.
It's become just kind of the,
the entertainment.
I think I enjoy a video that has jump cuts and then if I'm in my car,
I'm riding my bike,
I'm doing whatever.
That's when I listened to a podcast or if I might like relaxing.
If I'm at work and I have 12 minutes left on my break,
I want to try and get in as much as possible.
Well,
your videos are very entertaining.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean,
there's nothing bad about them,
but the jump cut thing,
it's just,
it's almost like it just grabs you,
right?
Like,
you can't let go.
this motherfucker's not gonna stop.
He's not going to stop talking.
I says one complete sentence that you know,
you're taking out every error,
every,
um,
every deep breath and everything,
you know,
it's just tonight.
Welcome to America Max headroom called it,
right.
Oh yeah.
Back in the day,
like all sort of,
kind of
first started,
it was,
it was much worse.
I,
uh,
because I would,
I would edit in imovie and so I could just shoot one part of a sentence at a
time and then change the frame.
And so if you go to my older videos,
it's very,
very jarring.
While in the new stuff sometimes maybe you get 25 seconds,
how many youtube followers do you have now?
You to somewhere in 3 million.
Jesus Christ,
I don't know,
how have you done this?
It's over eight years.
It's not like a lot of these,
the new young British kids that uh,
they just,
they make a video where they,
you know,
it's like five things I love and it's like 8 million views.
Yeah.
You've created.
What is the other thing that I like about you is you like me also like
chimpanzees.
Yes.
I noticed that your,
your logo has a chimpanzee on it.
What's that all about?
Um,
I don't know what it was.
No,
it's not even like a cool creative reason.
It's for just for greed,
estes monkey poster and my background,
the first two years of my,
my,
my youtube career if you want to call that.
And I was like,
I can't sell these,
so let's make our own.
And that's Hilarious,
man.
We,
we,
uh,
we did it.
3 million,
397,000 subscribers.
Damn some.
Should you stand in front of a camera mostly and just talking.
Yes.
Yeah,
we,
I've,
I've created a,
some new channels with different people just so that something can grow past me,
but for the most part,
I mean that's at the end of the day.
That's the main thing.
So you started a whole business because of this.
Yeah.
So I uh,
after doing this for awhile,
um,
youtube came to us and it was part of this like big youtube channel initiative,
I think they spent like $1,000,000 across
the board and like vice jumped in red bull,
a bunch of other things that aren't on there anymore.
Uh,
and so I create another channel called source fat.
And then from there,
source fed nerd.
Um,
and then after about a year and a half of that,
it was acquired by discovery.
And so now we're just making stuff with and for discovery.
There's so many of these guys out there doing this now.
I mean,
you were one of the first ones,
but like you can't keep up with how many people are just standing in front of a
camera commenting on,
you know,
whatever pop culture or the news,
politics,
things that are going on.
It's a,
it's really interesting that there is,
there's so many people that are really good at this.
I mean,
this is,
this is something where if we lived a decade ago,
there's no outlet for most of these people.
And so they would all have normal lives.
They would be in,
you know,
you would be in medical school or you'd be a doctor by now or someone would be,
whatever,
whatever other job they chose instead.
Now,
you know,
they've got a million,
2 million,
3 million followers on youtube that are hanging on every day waiting for new
videos to come out.
I mean,
you have a bunch of like really psycho obsessed fans.
I tried it.
I'm like psycho obsessed.
Uh,
there are a bunch of people that are really pumped.
There are people that have been with me for,
for eight years.
Like,
and that's for me,
that's like a lifetime people that,
you know,
I was wearing a backwards hat and I had stupid,
a fake,
a fake earrings and fake earrings.
Fake diamond and diamonds.
You know,
when you go to like Claire's when you're old.
I'm 29.
See when you're 29,
eight years is a long fucking time because the difference between 21 and 29.
It's like man,
you were a child and now you're a man.
Almost one year you'll be a man.
Yeah.
When I hit 30,
yeah.
That's when it starts sort of.
I've been waiting.
I've been waiting for it to feel that moment.
I mean if I met me when I was 30 I'd be like,
bitch,
you ain't a man.
Well yeah.
When I think about some of the stuff I said,
I mean I don't know if it.
Does that stop like when when you're 30 or you like I never said anything else I
ever regretted.
No,
it never stops.
I regret some shit.
I said an hour ago.
No,
getting around it is.
I mean as a human being,
you go,
wait.
I think.
I think the development of life is sorta like peaks and valleys sort of thing,
like you hit these peaks and then you fuck up and you,
you know,
just like we were talking about before about a tom score and you doing some sort
of a podcast where you lose weight yet the reality is you'll lose all that
weight and then you'll fucking get fat again for a little bit and then he tried
to lose all that weight and I think it's very difficult to completely change who
you are or to completely stop saying words that you've tried to cut out of your
vernacular or completely stopped doing certain things.
Like I was listening to bill burr the other day was talking about he's just
going to stop watching porn.
He stopped.
He hasn't watched porn like four days.
He's like talk like as if that's some sort of accomplishment.
You've,
you gone for days.
Congratulations.
You're not?
No.
Well,
can you think of what do you.
What's your number that have gone without watching porn?
Well,
when I've gone camping or have this like a week flew,
but then the moment I get to the hotel,
uh,
yeah,
probably.
It's probably never been more than a couple of weeks.
I've definitely gotten a couple of weeks just because I've been busy.
You know,
it's too accessible.
I'm just trying to think like what's,
what's the longest,
I don't know.
Did you watch it today?
Today?
I know I covered a story on pornhub for because they released him for
journalism.
Yes.
It's very serious.
I know it was,
uh,
it was just a story.
My whole thing is like bringing,
it kind of gets the HBO model where like every first season it's just like set
dirty,
sloppy sex in random scenes that make no sense and then they're like,
and we're going to keep you because it's really good.
Really good TV show.
Like big love,
big love was nothing but like for like the first season and then it was like,
and then here's the storyline.
So yeah,
we,
it was a what,
what countries last put longest?
Jesus Christ.
Is it China?
Wow.
I don't know why,
how,
how long they last a.
it's about,
on average it's 15 minutes and then in the United States,
Tempe,
Arizona is one of the shortest with five minutes.
And for some reason just coke hands
find that out a well.
They just looked at the amount of time someone stayed on a video page and then
left.
And then for some reason mountain view,
I don't know what's happening in mountain view,
but they last 21 minutes.
I don't know what they're doing.
Mountain view the last 21 minutes.
That's the average.
I don't know what they're doing.
They're probably distracted with mountain lions outside of their house or some
shit.
Put their parents up every couple of minutes.
Scratching at the door.
I don't know.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a weird time when it comes to porn as well because there's just never been
in any time in history where you could watch people fuck so easily.
I mean,
yeah man.
I,
I remember,
um,
it was like a big thing for me.
My parents were gone for two days and I was just trustworthy enough where they
will leave me at home and I remember when you would have to buy a three hour
block of playboy on it was like direct TV and I put a vhs and I was like,
I'm saving this forever.
And like,
and,
but then I was like afterwards,
where you like it afterwards,
where you realized you made a terrible decision.
You're just like,
oh no,
the bill is going to come.
And so I'm just waiting every day.
And uh,
and the bill comes in,
I open it up.
Um,
the steam thing doesn't work.
I have to rip it open.
Um,
but luckily we have our own things and uh,
and I take it out,
I scan it for some reason we have an old school because I don't know,
photoshop or whatever the equivalent is when I'm 16 years old.
And I like,
I faked an entire bill so that they would think I got titanic that's held there.
I was,
I was terrified.
But I was very proud of myself.
I was very proud of myself.
That's a brilliant way of handling it,
but it was.
It was a very in the moment terrified.
Oh my God,
what did I just do?
But they still paid the bill.
Yeah,
they paid so it was fine.
So they really never found out.
No,
never found genius.
It's like the one time I got away with something,
she'll tell him now,
just bring it up at Thanksgiving next year.
Here's the deal.
There was a time and those playboy blocks are fucking brutal anyway because you
never saw real.
I mean you kind of saw sex,
like they would show penetration for like a second or two,
but there was no cum shots.
I don't know why cum shots are important.
Usually no penetration in the hbo play or the playboy for the playboy stuff.
Some of them have a little.
I think right?
Sometimes just like there was shows that you're like,
why is this a thing?
There was sex court.
I don't know if anyone's ever remembered that.
It would just be like,
it would be a guy that was not paying enough attention to his wife and the judge
would like
suck his wife's tits
just like Josh down to it.
Right.
Just pass down some weird judgment.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
It's,
it's just,
it's Kinda odd that technology is fueled in a lot of ways by porn,
you know,
like html five.
Like when,
when that came along like that,
one of the earliest adopters was porn,
you know,
and because the iphone,
the ipads were using html five and they weren't using flash anymore.
Everybody's like,
all right,
fuck flash,
we're going to go with this.
I mean that's essentially what happened,
right?
Yeah.
But how is flashy even still alive to this day?
I have problems with flash every day.
Do you guys have the problems every day?
I always forget it's a thing until I have eight tabs open and then all of them
crash.
Yeah,
definitely crashes.
It's a,
it's just a weird sort of a thing and it's also got a weird reputation because
steve jobs was so anti flash and so like outward about some open about being
anti flash,
but yet it's still around
and it's still got holes in it.
It's still,
you know,
a big problem security wise and,
and now with a safari almost blocking flash to the point where videos won't work
and there's like this little banner that's supposed to pop up that says it's
like power setting mode or something that never does,
so then you have to like update the flash and it's just,
it's,
it's a pain in the ass.
There's so many things that are just happening.
Like I don't,
I still don't know what adobe reader is.
I just know that I updated it all of time.
What does it do for pdfs or you're right,
I don't know what that is.
Yeah,
what does adobe reader do?
Some of them will tweet us.
I'm sure they're like,
I don't,
I don't think I've ever looked into it.
I just always say yes.
All right.
Sign did not update the shit out of that stupid thing.
When you make your videos to you,
do you do it based on pop culture based on what's in the news based on Shit you
want to talk about,
like how do you,
how do you set out to create a video?
I think it's 70 percent,
uh,
stuff that I want to talk about.
It's a,
I always want to talk about one big worldwide story today.
I think it is actually the,
uh,
the Sony story because I mean,
this kind of,
if you think about it,
the stoner movie has somehow now turned into just an international conflict.
And then.
So that's the main story.
And then I opened with porn hub's stats because that's what you do.
And then,
uh,
share some,
some interesting videos.
And then there's one other thing.
I don't know.
I had to hurry up because I had to be able to make it here.
How many,
how many,
many minutes or videos?
Videos on average.
I get yelled at if they're young,
a long or the shorter than six minutes.
And yells at you.
The Internet.
Really?
Yeah,
because it used to be a two to three minutes show up because that would be the,
the amount I could actually try and keep it interesting.
And then it slowly became this seven to 12 minutes show and so that's what it is
usually a and yeah.
I'm trying to think if I ever go shorter.
Not really.
You could always put those pauses backend son now man.
And people would see how strange that fucker out 10 to 15 minutes.
Like I'm like I'm cringing inside with all my,
my little things where I say like,
oh,
like is rough,
like,
is rough and you know,
you know is a weird one.
You know,
there's this,
you know,
thing,
you know where you got,
you know,
this guy,
like I catch myself saying,
you know,
and I'm like,
you fucking dumb ass.
You better stop saying that stupid.
He just,
we all need those Obama pauses.
That's what we do.
Philip DEFRANCO.
Yeah.
That's what he does to keep from saying um,
or some people say fuck,
you know,
which is almost as bad.
Like it's fucking a fucking guy with the fucking thing with the [inaudible].
That's my dad.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
My Dad's.
My Dad's pure New Yorker.
So it's like every three words.
What do your parents think of this man?
This,
I mean,
you're,
you're what they call in quotes,
a youtube sensation.
Oh No,
you are.
You're smirking as you say that to your institution.
If I was going to describe you youtube sensation,
Philip de Franco,
and that's what you are.
You're a youtube sensation.
I've seen a dozen of your videos,
at least probably 20 years.
Sensation.
I watched a dozen of your videos.
You are in fact a sensation
to be honest though.
How many of you watched on accident?
None of them.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
usually most of the videos that I've watched have you,
is either someone put a bump on my message board,
you know,
they're like,
uh,
you know,
listen to this cool video or like in a,
in a,
um,
a thread maybe where you're talking about something that has to do with the
subject of the threat or someone will send it to me on twitter.
Okay.
You know,
but they're always really good points.
You're,
you were always really well measured in the things you talk about.
Like you,
you,
you're obviously thinking about these things in depth and you don't come at it
from any weird
ideology.
You look at things very balanced and I appreciate that.
Yeah,
I try to.
It's a,
I don't know,
I always think of just if someone yelled at me that I was wrong,
you know,
and didn't give me like any,
any possible getaway,
like give me an out,
give me,
give me something.
Uh,
but my parents,
uh,
they hated it first.
Really?
Did.
Yeah.
My,
well because we didn't know and made money for like the first first probably
four years.
Oh.
So they were like,
you're wasting your time.
Yeah.
When I was in,
when I was going through a premed in North Carolina,
one of the big things was I,
my grades started slipping.
I was kind of just doing it because it was a hobby and I was going to stop
making the videos.
But then youtube brought around the partner program which was just their way of
putting ads on it and you know,
you got money and there were all these big promises and then it turned out like
we were making pennies,
but it was,
it was still like this revenue,
which,
which was amazing to me.
Like making youtube videos and making money from it.
And now it's a whole thing because we're with discovery.
We have like a sales team in New York and just weird it.
I mean,
but we didn't make money for the first four years.
Yeah.
But that's why it's good.
It's kids like you did it because you were actually enjoying doing it and you
were enjoying the feedback and that sort of like an apprenticeship.
When you think about like to get a bachelor's degree,
you're doing for years,
so you did four years in youtube and then you graduated.
It's the 10,000 hours,
right?
Yeah,
I mean Shit.
10,000 hours.
That's a lot.
You know,
we haven't done 10,000 hours of podcasting thing.
We've done 580 something podcasts.
That's three.
Not always three sometimes too.
Yeah.
That's not.
It's not 10,000 hours.
It's fucking slot hours.
A long fucking time.
But I mean it's,
it's just the old school stuff and I don't know.
Everyone kind of had to change along with it.
There were a lot of people that were making videos back then that hated the
prospect of,
of money.
That money was going to ruin it all.
Like we're all going to be wearing like Pepsi shirts and it was all going to go
downhill,
but you just have to.
You have to just change with it.
Yeah.
That is the real fear,
right?
Is that corporate media comes in or corporate entities come in and buy you out,
give you an old for.
You can refuse a next thing you know,
you can't talk about anything controversial.
You get asked to wear certain clothes,
you get asked to talk about certain movies.
It would be good if you could talk about the interview.
It's our new film that's coming out.
Philip DEFRANCO.
I'm sure you have a positive review of the interview.
You know,
that kind of shit.
Yeah.
We're slowly.
We have a segment called calls from Collin because um,
because like I said,
some of the company was purchased by discovery and then we talked about the,
was the,
as the Anaconda video or the,
which one was a two hour special of the guy that got.
Oh yeah,
that asshole that didn't even get eaten and I just made fun of it and I just saw
that anytime anything is discovery and I'll be like,
I'm looking forward to your call,
Colin,
because I know that it's going to come down.
Well,
I don't know what the fuck they were thinking with that they put guy,
if you don't know
what we're talking about,
they put it was called eaten alive or something like that.
And so they put this guy in this armored sort of suit and they covered his body
and pig blood and then they sort of fed him to an Anaconda.
So the Anaconda wraps its body around him and just starts breaking this guy's
body and he taps out this pussy never got eaten at all at all.
Like that thing didn't even put a mouth on him.
It didn't even get its mouth over his head.
Yeah,
it was A.
I don't know,
I just sort of like bit.
I'm a little nibbled.
Yeah,
you got nibbled.
You got,
you got hugged.
He got cuddled.
Terrifying creature.
He got hugged mean they are fucking unbelievably strong.
And that's one of the things that I was thinking of when I was.
When I was hearing about this,
I was like,
well one of this guy is aware of what the pressure of that thing constricting
him is going to be like.
Because even if you're in a suit,
you're probably not going to be able to breathe.
Like the thing about what they do,
even if it doesn't swallow you whole,
is they wait for you to take a breath and then when you exhale that clamped down
so that you can't inhale again.
That's what they do.
It sounds so terrifying.
Oh,
they're the scariest things on the world.
Yeah,
but I mean,
I would've done the same thing.
I would've done the same thing was tapped out.
Yes.
I would've never done it.
I've been,
fuck you.
I'm not doing that.
I don't know.
I think it got great ratings.
Of course,
until they lied to us.
They lied to us.
They had a two hour show where a guy,
they knew that fucking guy didn't get eaten and they called it eaten alive.
He didn't even get fucking halfway swallow,
didn't even get his foot swallowed.
You know?
You think that's the way.
That's what went wrong.
He didn't start from the right way.
No,
they always start from the head and that's,
that's the snakes choice.
No,
the snake gets to decide.
What's really insane about anacondas is there's people in Brazil that swear that
they can get to 100 feet there.
There's people in Brazil,
especially people that have seen them like a long time ago that have seen
enormous ones like we don't really know like what the biggest ones are have
anacondas.
I think the biggest ones I've ever captured.
I've been like something like 30 or 40 feet or something like that,
but people believe that they can grow to 100 feet.
I have joined it.
You can tell me anything about anacondas and I'd be like,
that's amazing.
I'm not going to question it at all.
That's when you should.
If it's coming out of my mouth for sure you should question it,
but they're there.
The whole idea behind an animal or a snake that all what it does is grab a hold
of you and then wraps its body around you and crushes you and then swallows you
whole.
I mean if you see them when they have something inside their body,
they can expand like they can swallow it.
These enormous animals.
I'm not messing with that.
I'm not going anywhere that could possibly happen,
ever know,
but these goddamn discovery channel shows or any of these,
is that discovery it was discovered,
right?
Yeah.
There's so many of these goddamn shows where they're doing this now where
they're,
they're sort of baiting you in to watch them with these stents and then when you
actually do watch it,
like how about those Goddamn Mermaid?
I can't.
To this day,
people believe that those animal planet shows were revealed.
These mermaids are real.
They never said that it was a piece of fiction.
They never did.
They made a documentary.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
No,
I know that like I'm scarred because there was like,
there was a show that was on Fox when it was,
when I was like 10 years old and it was,
it was like I looked back and it was obviously fake,
but at no point during it did they say that this alien abduction thing was
faking?
Oh yeah,
that's right.
For,
for years.
Yeah.
That one was crazy because no one ever took credit for that one.
Right.
I don't even remember what it is.
I just,
it's just in my brain of I was terrified of this for three,
four years.
Yeah.
They,
um,
that was one where everybody really was convinced that that was a real alien and
there was a bunch of people that were like supposedly special effects.
Designer just said we can't even do that.
They always,
they get some dummy that's like a makeup artist is like we're not even capable
of doing that today.
And then,
you know,
you talked to like Rick Baker characters like A.
Yeah,
we are like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You assholes,
but all you need is one person to get on camera and say that.
And you know,
maybe.
Yeah,
whoever,
whoever made that was the guy.
Like that's how he was able to get a drastic park because like if you look at
drastic park,
that shit's awesome.
Like that's all CGI though.
No,
but I mean I'm talking about like the first one compared to where we are today.
Like if you look at the first one,
how
vanced two amazing ones.
Yeah.
I just watched it the other day with my four year old.
She was not digging it.
Six year old loved it.
The four year old was like,
fuck this.
She buried her head in her mom's lap and started crying and screaming when,
when the t rex was chasing the cheap,
she checked out right there.
That was enough.
She was fine.
When the Brontosaurus is,
we're moving around,
but as soon as the t rex came around and ate the goat,
it was all downhill from there.
Point is,
it is super important to stay away from scary TV for kids because I have a new
one.
It's
a good question.
I think that,
um,
I mean,
what is scary?
it's good to expose them to reality in a certain sense.
Like to let them know that there's good people,
but there's also the potential bad people without actually bringing them to
prison.
Say,
look,
these are the guys,
the tattoos on their face.
Stay away from them son.
I don't know.
I mean it's,
um,
it's a good question.
Like I think we're entirely too scared as a culture by media in a certain way.
I mean,
I know people that just watch those God damn serial killer shows,
you know,
those shows where they profile serial killers or talk about serial killers or,
or they talk about love gone wrong and you know this.
I have a friend who watches all of those.
All those hasn't Dvr,
just can't,
can't turn from these goddamn shows on psychos.
Yeah.
I think the,
uh,
I think like the demo of that are 60 year old women at home.
I'm pretty.
It's murder part.
Yeah.
It is murder porn.
That's what Duncan Gaza to.
Yeah.
That's really the best way to describe it.
It really,
you get some sort of a weird thrill out of like listening to this story about
how this guy bought all this acid and say saved it up and you know,
got a tub and put it in the woods and chop the lady up and you'll choose.
Well it's like CSI,
but real life,
you know?
Yeah.
That is weird.
When you see them in court and the shackle do like that.
The guy that did it,
that fucking guy really did it.
Yeah.
I mean,
but I'm not above it.
I,
I know that I,
I searched a lot like forever on itunes and all over the web to to watch a show
called.
It was like the first 48 and I was just,
I was trying to go through the top 10 and I was like,
oh,
this is a terrifying.
And it's like the number one is,
it's just like a guy killed seven people and they're all a part of his family
and it all and you're just like,
what is this is like life.
This is like,
how do you do that?
That's a weird,
like a weird reality that some people can go off the rail completely and just
kill everyone in their family,
including kids.
They can kill their kids.
See?
That scares me.
Oh yeah.
Because I have a son now that's a seven and a half months and I just,
everyday when you look at the news,
it's like this,
this child.
Well,
because in New York,
that kid or that guy cut his mom's head off and kicked through the street on
Halloween,
like that's a.
that's a thing that mom was account though
I heard she was a con.
Like in church.
She was always telling him to turn the TV down.
Shit like that.
Go to bed.
Yeah.
She was always telling them,
pay rent.
You gotta pay rent.
Fuck her.
She made him.
He didn't ask to be born.
Did you hear about this video game?
Actually you covered it the other day.
Hatred.
Yeah.
That's.
Oh,
is that the one where you had the video asking if it should be censored?
Yeah,
it's one of those things where I look at the game and I try and think of
everything that I've played in the past and I've played super,
super gory violent games like manhunts and I loved it and like you're looking at
strat guides on how to get the more,
the more vicious,
more vicious kill on someone in a manhunt.
And I think it's more of just from the outset,
the way that it's being portrayed as it seems like,
Hey,
you know,
that guy that goes to a movie theater and kills everyone.
What if you were that guy?
And so and so it's,
it's a game that I don't know if I'm going to play,
I might play it so that I can cover it.
But I also understand that yeah,
maybe it shouldn't be censored,
you know,
that's my,
that's my thing.
It's one of those things that's a gray area for me.
Fucking crazy people's head off with a shotgun.
There was also a scene.
Yeah,
the massive stabbing.
And so it's one of those for me,
it is something where I'm like,
I'm trying to get where I try and get past myself because my reaction and I.
you're not showing this on the show,
are you?
Yeah,
just pieces of it.
It's,
it's a video game.
Trailer Video Games though.
All right.
But don't just in case.
Yeah.
But so we get pulled off youtube for everything.
We showed nature videos and anytime we show a video and we go over and talk
about the video,
we get pulled for some youtube copyright fucking horseshit,
but it's a good point.
Like what,
at what point in time as a culture do we say,
Hey,
what the fuck is this?
Like this isn't even like a hero is going around killing bad guys in a very
violent manner.
Like you just like.
So that's certainly killing people.
So that's like,
that's the main difference.
When someone makes a comparison to manhunt,
it's usually you think,
okay,
bad guy or you know,
crazy backstory guy killing other bad guys.
Um,
this with just kind of a mass killing of innocent people.
You also have to wonder,
we've only seen one trailer,
you know,
is there,
is there something where there is,
there is a story there or is it just intended to make people angry?
But I always look at video games,
uh,
some,
some aren't,
but some I think are like any form of entertainment,
art in some way,
you know,
it is,
it,
is it supposed to make you really nervous,
right?
Like when you see that and you're like,
oh shit,
like that's fucking crazy.
How is this a thing for me?
I go,
okay,
that's,
that's a good thing.
It's a conversation.
It's something that goes a step deeper and that kid right that they've said
killed someone because of grand theft auto call of duty.
I mean this is just going to get tagged on.
Maybe that guy plays that game,
but I know that I play grand theft auto and I run over people.
I wouldn't do that in real life.
Not a psychopath
do because it's a goof because you also,
you know,
there are not real people.
Exactly.
And it's kind of naughty,
naughty to just run people over for fun.
You just highlighting what will you just highlight the,
the actual game.
Like the description of the games kind of fucked up though.
It says,
yeah,
he says like,
I just hate the world and the human worms feasting on its carcass.
My whole life is just cold,
bitter hatred and I always wanted to die violently the time for vengeance and no
life is worth saving and I'll put in a grave as many as I can.
I mean that alone is just like crazy.
Like he get to be Michael Myers from Halloween,
you know,
if he played Halloween and you've got to be the psycho,
is that a valid piece of art because people are running away from you,
but is that only valid if you're the good guy?
Yeah,
but that's a little bit of fake compared to this is realistic.
This is you going into a mall and killing cops and children and stabbing them
and blowing their heads off with shotguns where Jason's like a monster that
lives in a lake or something.
Right.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
I mean obviously I don't want to have anything to do with it.
I didn't want to plant,
but should it be censored as the real question?
Right,
right.
So what happened was it was taken off of,
uh,
of,
and then it was put back on once a,
one of the homeowners looked into it.
And was like,
I don't think this is a valid reason,
this is us making it too personal.
This was part of a game coming to the forefront because people voted for it to
be up.
Whether it's because they wanted to troll the general public or because they
wanted to generally play this game and it,
it,
it is always the question,
are we protecting people by it not being a thing or are we just telling grown
adults what they're allowed to do?
Yeah.
But that,
that is the question,
right?
Yeah.
It's.
And that's why I say it's a gray area because you know,
kids are going to get a hold of this and who becomes the arbiter of common sense
or decency becomes the who becomes the judge as to what is and is not
detrimental to society.
That looks like detrimental to me.
I mean it's like you're entering into that realm of like the full extreme like,
you know,
like faces of death.
Is that a,
is that,
you know,
when you watch those faces,
death,
is that actually entertainment or you just freaking yourself out watching
horrific things and who the fuck has filming that stuff?
Snuff films,
you know,
who,
who's filming those things?
Were faces of death real.
Some of them.
There was news footage mixed with fake.
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
I just know that I went out when that was a thing.
I think it was like 10 years ago,
like an east.
I was just like,
I was freaked out by the idea and I never wanted to.
Got It.
Yeah.
How much of faces?
Death is fake?
Like we're real.
Someone like the guy who shot himself in the head,
the cop or the,
uh,
the judge in the courtroom.
That was that faces of death.
Uh,
yeah,
there was like the train,
the woman running across getting that was real.
That was real.
But then like the blood orange,
which was my favorite part growing up,
uh,
that was fake and where everyone's fucking and yeah,
that was great.
What about when they knocked a monkey over the head and ate its brains?
I think that was fake,
but I'm not sure what that one where they're knocking it with a little hammer
and then they take the monkey brains out like stir and then eat it.
By the way,
the worst thing you could ever eat on a monkey is the brains because of monkeys,
like really close to a human being.
That'd be like eating human brains,
which is how they get prions.
That's how those guys New Guinea wind up getting Jacob crutchfield disease.
The same thing as mad cow.
Well,
you get it from eating brain tissue.
Cows get it from eating brain tissue of other cows.
It's some neurological disease that come.
It's like nature's protection from cannibalism.
Nature's nature.
Like if you become someone who prays on the same species as you,
nature has sort of this built in fail safe mechanism to make your body shut
down.
I like stuff like that.
I get if you're in an area where that's the only thing,
but when.
When I think of brain,
like someone eating monkey brains,
I just imagine like some guy that has way too much money.
Yeah.
Just everything in life is boring and he's like,
let's do this.
Yeah.
Some like most dangerous game type dude.
Once a month,
humans releases them from his mansion and attracts them through his country.
Estate.
Yeah.
Was that an ice tea movie was right.
Whether was what it was.
Uh,
it was also a,
uh,
please pauly pauly shore movie.
There was a,
there was a Polish.
So many pauly shore.
Come on Google it for real.
You already wrote philly directly into your Google bar.
I really have a Deleno Lena Dunham.
Okay.
When you bring up video games,
this is an interesting time with video games as well because there's all this
Gamergate shit going on.
You know,
this always saw this,
this take on women in gaming and feminism and gaming and you know,
a lot of people think that certain segments of,
of gaming has been cooperated by extreme feminism's.
Pauly shore is dead now,
but that was,
that was different.
That was a new one.
Yeah.
Pauly shore.
His Dad was like him.
He was faking his own death,
right?
Yeah,
I think so.
I don't know if that was a movie he maybe I'm thinking of something else.
Yeah,
maybe.
But there was a definitely an ice tea version and there was a really old version
called the most dangerous game and I think it's based on an old book or an old
story,
at least perhaps a short story.
I don't know.
Yeah,
that Gamergate stuff.
I just try and stay.
I just try and stay away,
man.
It's too much.
Well,
there are people that are having an actual conversation and then there are
people that think they're actually having a conversation.
They're just yelling at each other.
Um,
and then.
And then obviously then you have the harassment and it just,
any way you touch it,
it's bad.
Well,
the harassments awful,
you know,
and the feminism,
the overreaction and the,
the,
the overreaching and some of the most ridiculous,
ludicrous points about toxic masculinity and attaching that to like school
shootings and things on.
That's ridiculous too.
But it's not hurting anybody.
Like they're just,
they just have goofy opinions,
like with the,
the harassment is the worst part of it and I think the harassment that's coming
from the side of the pro Gamer gators,
it's only a few people,
but it fucks up the whole conversation.
I think most people are like,
look,
we want to watch video games that have girls with big tits.
Okay.
We want to.
And it's okay.
It's just like it's okay to have big tits and porn just like it's okay to,
you know,
it's,
it's their goddamn like superheroes.
Okay.
It's like comic book stuff.
It's not supposed to be real.
It doesn't have to represent reality.
Whether it's phoenix from thex men or whether it's,
you know,
Laura Croft,
tomb raider,
like cartoonish representations of human beings is fine.
Just like he man,
master of the universe was not anti male.
You know,
when you have these women that have these ridiculous proportions and you know,
they have stereotypical roles in these movies.
That doesn't mean the movie's bad.
It doesn't mean it's detrimental to society.
It doesn't mean it's detrimental towards a male female relations or female
empowerment.
That's nonsense is nonsense,
you know,
people will treat human
how they are going to treat them based on how they grew up based on the
education they received based on a lot of variables.
I don't think video games factors that heavily into that.
I feel like the reason video games are there,
it's,
it's a soft target.
Uh,
and it's just,
it's constantly,
there's constantly new stuff.
I don't know,
I just don't.
I don't think about it that much.
I know that I like playing games and everyone else can argue.
Well,
I used to play as a chick in when I played quake.
I played when I played quick,
I always played as the church.
You know why?
Because it's,
it's fun when she jumps,
when she jumps,
she goes,
she would make that noise when she jumps and she was a smaller target.
That's why we play as a chick because in quake three,
like you could be that big fucking robot,
but if you were there big fucking robot,
everybody could see really good.
If you,
that little tiny chick this jumping around,
it's a better character to play with.
I was just talking to Jamie about this the other day because I only play as girl
characters in video games.
Always have.
Well yeah,
but,
but if I go,
hey,
Jamie was paying as it plays as a guy and I play played that girl.
But like Jamie,
I was like,
I asked him why do you play as a,
a guy?
I mean like if you had to sit there and watch a guy walk around for three hours,
like just as,
but for three hours that would be gay as fuck if you just sat there and watched
a guy.
But if you watch the girls but the third person.
So looking at.
Yeah,
yeah.
I always played in first person but yeah,
you're right.
Why?
What is everyone like video game gay.
Jamie doesn't want anybody think he's gay and he wants to go way out of the way
so
he doesn't want anybody thinking that he secretly wants to be a woman.
It's cute though because when we play together it's like we're on a date because
he's like,
I'm like this hot chick and he's with this guy and should see his character.
It's all like,
hey,
I'm cool.
Look at engineering.
You know,
I don't,
I don't want to play any game like this fucking murder violence game,
whatever it's called.
What is it called?
Hatred,
hatred.
I don't want to play this game,
but if you want to make that game,
I can't stop you from making that game.
Just like,
I can't stop you from listening to fucking speed metal.
You know,
just like I can't stop you from watching violent,
gory movies.
You know?
There's a lot of violent,
gory moves I don't have nothing to do with.
But who's to say who the fuck?
There's a lot of like functional,
normal,
rational people that like to watch fucked up shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
but the thing that thing a lot of people need to get around is whether something
is being censored in the,
in the sense of like the government and the censored in the sense of a private
company.
One of the big things gta five was was pulled off of shelves and target,
I think in Australia.
There was another place in Australia that pulled it and a lot of it was because
of the treatment of people saying that the treatment of women in that game was
wrong.
Yeah.
There's a lot of holes in that game.
Right?
You could run them over and shit.
Smacking Gum.
You could fuck them.
You go to a strip club.
Fuck.
You can.
Well you can fucking your car and so you go to the Strip club and you can pick
up a girl and give her money.
Yeah,
you can get hookers
and then they start calling you and then you can meet for dates and then I
wonder if it would go away if they just made a like a dude strip club,
like an guy prostitutes,
if any would be there.
Oh Wow.
There you go.
Oh,
how dare you.
It's so unfair.
They did not.
If they did that,
I'd be the first person to jump in,
game recorded on youtube and be like,
look,
it's the first dude onto blow job.
If I.
well,
I think that once I've been talking about this onstage,
I think that once they develop artificial men like artificial human beings,
like blade runner style,
it's going to come.
There's going to be women that have sex robots in their house and we're gonna.
Find out what women really like when,
when when you can actually buy a person that is an artificial person that was
created entirely in a lab and you could manufacture their personality and get it
to exactly where you want it to be and have them do anything you want them to
do.
They're essentially robot sex slaves.
You're going to go over your grandma's house and she's going to have five,
seven foot tall Zulu warriors had just throw declutter all day.
That's going to be the reality.
That's what it's going to be.
You're going to go over your mom's house and everyone is going to look like
Arnold Schwarzenegger in his prime and they're all going to be walking around
with Whitey tighties on a giant hogs at black arnold.
Maybe.
Maybe she likes them all mixed up.
Maybe she likes Arnold Arnold.
I mean,
they'll going to be able to recreate celebrities.
I mean Jennifer Lawrence is not just going to be on the cloud.
You're going to have her in your fucking dungeon going to have her locked up.
That's going to be real.
Look,
it's not that difficult to do.
If they can make a three d representation of her right now,
which is pretty accurate.
I mean the the graphics that they can do right now in video games are fucking
incredible and the CGI that can do is incredible and then you've seen that robot
Japanese face where it's getting pretty creepy.
It's getting pretty creepy.
They're getting really close to human beings.
They haven't bridged even at videos with.
What does that,
that,
that valley,
they call it,
they call it the Erie Valley or I forget the term that they use.
That is the difference between look like me,
you looking at you,
I'm looking at you.
I know you're really there and there's just weirdness when you're looking at an
excellent representation of a CGI human.
Like we went to the Nvidia m,
a headquarters in northern California when I was doing the Scifi show and we saw
the latest,
greatest high tech version of human beings that they've created and it's
incredible.
It's so good.
But there's still some shit.
They can't do like tongues.
They can't,
they can't like do like,
it doesn't look like a real tongue and it doesn't look like real eyelashes and
the eyeballs were a little off.
I think in the future that we're going to be growing all our parts as soon as
we're allowed to do that,
we're going to be growing fake tongues.
Oh yeah.
And,
and,
and that's
what's going to change where it's actually real skin,
but inside it's a robot,
but it feels real.
Sex feels real for sure.
I mean the robots are going to be made out of some sort of artificial skin that
is indistinguishable from regular skin.
It's going to be heated to the same temperature as a regular person's body.
I mean the insides will probably be just artificial organs and some sort of a
weird construction.
And then that's gonna Happen Man.
And when that happens,
you're going to find out what people actually like because I think a lot of what
people complained about,
it's like people feel they feel disempowered.
You know,
like women who don't look anything like Laura Croft,
like sexism in video games,
the patriarchy.
It's horrible for male female relationships,
chauvinist men who exists on white privilege and.
But if you could have seven,
seven foot Tall Zulu warriors throw a dick at you all day,
you would,
you'd lie on bitch.
You would lock yourself up in your house.
You wouldn't tell word you didn't walk out of your house all frumpy and fucked
up.
Just Been Dick defied all day confused.
Your hair's going to be in a bundle and you would give up on all your feminism.
Engaging bullshit.
Unless that was how you made a living.
It would be interesting.
It would be interesting to see what your friends,
like,
what their version of what their perfect girl would be.
It'd be interesting to see if like if everybody was Asian,
you know Amanda would change for men with the reality of men is we have DNA that
is designed to want to have sex with as many people as possible because that is
the reason why the human race made it 2014.
The human race didn't make it a 2014 because men were eager for monogamy and
once they're woman died,
they could never love another like in these fucking goofy ass movies and books.
No.
The reality is men want to fuck everything.
You know,
we just can't.
And why?
Why can't we can't because we either aren't attractive enough or we can't
because we have a girlfriend and she doesn't want us to or we can't because we
have a family.
Whatever,
for whatever reason,
you want to stick your Dick in a lot of different things and the reason being is
because you read Dna.
It's,
it's like super simple society and our culture and our feelings for other people
or the only thing that keeps us from doing that.
I don't know if there's anyone that's against sex robots.
I think that if the stuff that you're talking about,
like I'm sure many wives would be like,
yes,
give.
My husband said,
Oh shit,
he's fucking bull shit.
She'll power.
That dude will get divorced leg a lot.
Yeah,
he will do whatever he wants.
He will be going golfing whenever he wants.
He's not going to listen to anybody anymore.
If you have some traci lords in her prime sex robot at your house,
guess what?
Your wife can't tell you shit that bitch better.
Shut the fuck up.
You're lucky if you feed her.
She's like,
she's lucky if you let her stay in the house like you need to sleep where the
dog sleeps.
You can't sleep in my house anymore.
You've been telling me what to do for 20 years and women the same thing you
think are going to deal with their
fucking beer.
Bellied stupid husband and it's Stinky Dick.
You know they're not going to.
They're going to be like,
look Harry,
it's over.
You know I got arnold,
one,
two and three behind me.
Three fucking Arnold Schwarzenegger's with giant hogs in their underwear is
going to be,
oh,
we're going to,
you know,
everybody's worried about population control.
The real problem is going to be not enough people having babies because no one
wants to have anything to do with biological people because everybody's just
fucking these absolutely perfect sex robots.
Um,
I'm,
I'm all for it.
I think.
I think once we got past all the weird sex shit that we keep inside,
right?
Because then you don't have to have another person judging you.
We can,
we can hate each other for good reasons.
I honestly think as much as I really truly enjoy sex and I enjoy pleasure and I
think affection is like one of the best things in life.
Not just like sex,
but just hugging people.
You know,
it's,
it's beautiful.
You know,
there's something really awesome about affection,
but I think one of the things that's holding back human beings and one of the
things that keeps us in this sort of animalistic state is this competitive
desire to be attractive,
to find attractive people to,
you know,
to be sexually attractive and to mate with sexually attractive people.
This is all like weird sort of confusing shit that kind of keeps us from being
the next level of enlightenment and reaching the next level of enlightenment.
And when you look at aliens,
you know the archetype,
Gray Alien,
they have gi Joe,
Dick's like,
there's nothing there,
right?
They're totally smooth.
They have no muscle,
they have no.
There's nothing sexually attractive about an alien.
They're just like these,
these sort of like almost insectoid,
you know,
smooth body,
smooth limb.
There's nothing curvaceous or sweaty or animalistic or there's nothing kinetic
about them.
They have these giant fucking heads,
this little slip for a mouse because he probably don't even use their mouths
anymore.
They just communicate with their brains and they have super powered brains that
can move shit with their mind.
That's probably where the future is going to be.
If they could figure out a way to recreate pleasure in a much more intense way
than you ever get from sex and just do it like with the mind if they could
figure out a way to do that.
Demolition man.
Yeah.
You're not going to need a.
you're not going to need to fuck people anymore.
Yeah.
But I think like,
so when someone made that alien,
right?
It's all smooth.
Everything in the future is minimalistic.
Do you want to be the guy that draws a dick on it?
Like,
because you'll be that guy that was like,
it should have a dick though.
It should have a dick and less.
Well that was.
Look,
if you go to the uh,
you know,
I had to study this for.
I didn't have to,
but I read about it a lot firsthand just for my own amusement.
But then when I was doing this Scifi show,
I had to really get into alien abduction and to figure out like what are the
common themes?
And the common theme is these people to get abducted.
They all say that the aliens need our genetic material because they only
reproduced through cloning now and they need fresh DNA.
That's what they say,
but they also say,
you know,
the,
the real problem with all that stuff is this.
People that get abducted or all goofy,
like almost all of them.
I think that I believe in aliens.
I just don't know if they're abducting us.
I don't know.
I don't think so,
but I definitely,
I think there has to be something else.
Well,
there should be something out.
Will.
The idea of infinity.
This is,
was explained to me by a physicist who said that the universe is so large that
if it is in fact infinite.
Not only is there a you somewhere in the universe,
but there is a you that has lived every second of your life exactly the way you
have with every other event on earth happening in the exact same order and an
infinite number of them.
So not just one Philip Defranco that has been on Youtube for eight years and has
3 million,
397,000 youtube,
but an infinite number of them.
And every nod that you've done this,
Philip to Franco has done every smile like you just did.
Every Philip to Franco in the universe has done that.
And all other possible variables.
Blake Philip,
prank,
staying in law school up to Franco becoming a gay method.
Fill up every possible variable that you could have done in your life is being
done throughout the universe.
That's how big infinity is.
Yeah.
I think when I have those conversations though,
I get.
I get like,
are you still freaking out about this concept?
It's a mind fuck Philip to Franco damn mind.
Fuck.
I mean,
is it,
is it all those small little infinite changes or like are you talking about
dinosaurs on skateboards in infinity is a thing.
Yeah,
it's possible.
The infinity is so big that there's truly no end to it.
Like it literally has no end.
There is no end to the universe.
See,
my small eight brain goes,
no,
you can't.
It's beyond our capacity.
It's like taking an iphone six and wavering over an ant going,
look,
I got the new shit and doesn't know what the fuck you talking about.
It can't.
You can't look 16 megapixel camera,
128 gigs.
The aunt has zero capacity for,
for absorbing that information and I think when you get to something that is as
big as the concept of infinity,
but we're better at understanding the concept of infinity than a chimp or then
our ancient ancestors,
you know,
then uh,
Australia pithy,
gus,
you know,
what,
whatever,
you know,
ancient hominid.
So I think that as our technology grows and as our understanding of the universe
grows,
most likely slowly but surely our capacity to understand that will grow as well.
But certain things like infinity,
it's so far away.
It's so,
it's so far away like intellectually for us to wrap our head around.
I don't think we really can.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I just remember in college just waking up in the middle of the night terrified
of those thoughts.
Right?
Because it's just,
it's too big.
It's just,
it's,
it's terrifying.
I mean,
I'm okay with not mattering in the grand scheme of things,
but just to think that it's just so big.
Well then there's the fractal notion of the universe,
which is even more fucked up,
which is as big as the universe is,
that it really is just one atom that is in a person that exists in another
universe that is also infinite or it's all part of like a computer program that
always movies.
There was like four of them that came out in two years.
Yeah.
Well that's not just a movie man.
That's.
There's this guy,
a gates.
What is his name?
James Gates.
The,
uh,
he's an astrophysicist.
Or is he a quantum physicist?
One of those guys,
string theorists.
Three years.
He has done all these computations on string theory and he's found this
underlying computer code self-correcting computer code in all of the equations
to string theory.
I don't understand what the fuck this guy saying he's going,
he's coming on the podcast we're going to have.
We're flying them in.
Really?
Yeah.
You're staying home for that one.
No fucking way.
There's no way.
Why is it staying home?
He'll fuck that up.
They'll start talking about poop or something like that and I'll get confused.
It gets distracting,
but this guy has come up with these theories that are based on his self
correcting computer code that was discovered by human beings like the 19
thirties,
the this,
this self correcting code.
He's isolated this and identified this in all of these,
these string theory computations,
so what he believes is that in some way,
this may be proof that we are in some sort of a computer simulation and that one
day without a doubt,
we will have the capacity if we don't blow ourselves up,
if we don't get hit by an asteroid,
Dyna,
super volcano,
whatever we will have the capacity of technology continues to expand.
An exponential rate will have the capacity to create some sort of an artificial
reality that is indistinguishable from this reality and if that's the case,
how do we know that we're not already in it?
It is quite possible that we are already in it and that's not just stoner dummy
fear factor host talk.
You know,
this is actually like physicists,
this is actually like people who are studying this stuff from an objective
educated perspective
and it's cool,
but when other than finding out if it,
if it is a real thing,
do you think the.
Does it change anything?
Yes.
In what way?
Do you could just fucking go out and
go balls out out right now?
Yeah,
but he go to jail.
I know you're going to find the code and then you're gonna be able to change it
so you don't go to jail.
No,
I don't think you can do that.
I mean I think there's been like any game,
if you're playing a game,
there's rules to that game.
Right?
Right.
If you,
if you do something,
it takes away your health and power,
you know?
I mean that's what happens is you get on heroin in this game.
I mean there's certain,
there's certain things that people do in this world where if you think about it,
if you were a completely objective and you're standing on the outside and you
were going,
well,
what is going on there?
Oh,
they're playing a game and they have,
you know,
x amount of years in this game and you know,
you have cells and everybody's given a different character and everybody has a
certain amount of points you're trying to achieve.
Like I had this friend that,
uh,
used to manage the comedy store.
You remember rob from the comedy store.
Brian Guy that works in Phoenix now.
No.
Rob Was the guy that was addicted to everquest
and he was completely addicted to everquest and this poor bastard would come to
the comedy store and he was Pale.
He would like be Ashen,
like he looks sick at all.
He was doing for like 12,
13,
14 hours a day,
was sitting in front of his computer and playing everquest.
And he said like,
I'm so good at making money in everquest but so bad at doing it in real life.
And I remember thinking like,
you're playing the wrong game,
like you're in this game,
but this game is,
you've got to play this game.
The way you're playing that game.
Like if you went around this game life,
the actual life that the knock on wood life that you could feel if you played
that as,
if it's a game the same way you're playing everquest as if it's a game boy,
you know,
you would,
you would do amazing.
I mean your fucking balls to the walls for 12 hours a day playing this game
where you were a Goblin or some shit.
You got a battle ax and run them through more door.
What people.
I mean,
some people make tons of money from that now.
Right.
Well,
so I mean,
there,
there's the old school way,
which was a currency stuff.
I was a,
I was a big nerd.
I played,
uh,
what was it?
It was like a star wars mmo and then they ruined.
It was an MMO,
a massive multiplayer online game.
Most people listening to this don't know what the fuck.
Sorry,
sorry.
I people in before I got on,
Lindsey was,
my fiance was like,
be specific.
Sometimes you just glaze over shit that no one knows gets.
Oh yes.
Yeah,
man,
she's,
she's my biggest critic,
which is good.
My wife just tells me not to be retarded.
I'm like,
too late bitch.
I wish that was a word that was.
That was easier to use without getting crowded.
You can use it.
You just got to fucking.
Not Given.
It's not a medical term.
Okay.
Retarded means to retard to be slower.
Some people are retarded.
They are slower in catching on to other folks.
It doesn't mean you're mocking a disease and I'm not letting it go.
I'm holding onto retard with my greasy Guinea pause until the bitter end.
See,
I say that until they arrest me.
I say that in 24 to 48 hours,
there's a tumbler post with $200,000 like reblogs,
but it's like tell him to suck your Dick.
Oliver.
Tell those dummies to fuck off.
They're all fucking children.
They're all fools.
Okay.
It doesn't mean you're an unkind person and you're saying retarded.
You're not saying it around.
Oh look,
there's certain terms I won't use.
Okay.
I won't call someone a nigger.
I won't call it.
I stopped using faggot.
I'll use it with Brian occasionally when there's no one around,
but we're friends and I'm joking.
You know,
I don't,
but I won't use it.
I never use it when I'm talking about a gay person.
I will not use any.
I won't ever marginalize someone based on some things that they can't control or
whoever they are,
but when someone's retarded,
it just means they're being an idiot,
you know,
and it's not as good to say they're an idiot.
Like you fucking retard.
That's the right one.
That's what you want to say.
You know,
and it's,
it's not a medical term.
It never has been.
It used to be mongoloid idiot.
They used to actually say that on people's first.
Soon as you said,
it was like there was something in my chest that hurts.
You have a child.
Yeah.
It's horrible.
It's horrible that they,
that we were so insensitive that used.
We used to say mongoloid idiot,
but it does feel like there's this list,
right?
That stuff's just slowly getting crossed off.
Bitch.
You're not supposed to say,
bitch,
this a new one.
Come all bells on the podcast.
He said he gave up on the b word.
I'm like,
what be word is this?
What are you saying?
He won't say you can't say thug.
I think that was a new one.
It was thug.
They were trying to do that with bossy.
Do you remember that?
Bossy?
Yes.
Feminists.
We're trying to push the elimination of bossy because Bossy was disempowering
young women to call young women bossy.
Oh,
she's so bossy.
Like they were trying to and everybody went.
Not yet.
We're not that retarded yet.
We're not going to let you get rid of bossy.
Yeah,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
There's a bunch of social retards out there.
That's a big part of the problem there.
It is.
Bad bosses.
I heard him say socially retarded.
I was like,
what's he going to be bossy?
Banning Bossy.
There's nothing wrong with saying bossy.
Goddammit.
Pledged to ban bossy and pledged to fuck you.
Tumbler went fucking psychos and they include kids in the campaigns.
Yeah.
Well,
well,
what was that beyond say on the band?
Bossy bandwagon.
You're against.
Oh Dude,
you're against.
You're against B.
I'm against be.
If she's against b,
he's against the p word.
That's so crazy.
People are God damn crazy.
They're crazy people.
I feel like it's like their job.
Some fields to just get angry at stuff.
Well,
you know what it is.
People have the ability to affect some form of change.
You know how you touch your screen and you see that,
you know,
you touch the LCD screen,
you see that weird indentation where your finger is and you're like,
Ooh,
I could change the screen with my finger,
and so you just start poking at it and some of it makes sense and some of it
doesn't.
But there's a bunch people out there that are
incredibly over-sensitive,
you know,
the social justice warrior crowd.
Incredibly oversensitive and looking to like in some way pasteurize culture and
boil it down to this like completely inoffensive.
Always punching up,
you know,
sort of a environment.
And that's what,
that's the same sort of mentality that's trying to take away victory in
children's games.
They don't want anybody to win because then someone has to lose.
Well,
guess what?
Fuck face.
That's how we get better.
You get better by feeling like shit,
you know,
one of the ways you get better socially,
you get rejected,
you know,
that's what happens.
Like girls go,
you're a fucking loser and you go,
damn,
I'm a loser.
And then he'd go home and you get your shit together.
Yeah.
When I was,
when I was little,
I uh,
I went to a,
I went to,
it was like,
it was always like a subway or something and then like a karate studio right
next to it.
And I went there and I loved it for two years.
And then I went to my first tournament,
I played like eighth and they,
the guy that ran it gave me a trophy for second place and when we got home my
dad was like,
we're throwing this out.
You didn't earn this.
And it's important.
It's important to earn stuff.
Yeah.
It is important to earn stuff.
It's also important to realize if you're freaking out at a lot of the things
that we're saying right here,
I don't really mean this 100 percent.
You know,
like when I'm saying looked at twitter who were like,
oh no,
no,
I'm sure it's happening,
but I don't,
I don't really mean it when I'm saying like
when I'm here,
here's a problem.
People are extremely sensitive about certain subjects and when people joke
around about those subjects,
people freak out,
you know,
and it doesn't mean that you're a bad person.
It doesn't mean that you really hate anybody,
but people like to have fun and talk shit and when people like to have fun and
talk shit and people jump all over it as if this is some sort of a statement
they're giving a court like some sort of an affidavit,
like you're,
you're missing out on the subtle nuances of human interaction.
Like people say things that they don't really mean because it's funny,
right?
Because they're fucking around.
Yeah.
I think what Bill Burke covers that in his new,
a new special on Netflix.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
It's just like people taking stuff where it's like,
obviously I'm joking.
I don't think I should beat my wife.
Well,
I had a whole bit about it in my comedy central special about,
about,
uh,
Tracy Morgan about Tracy Morgan's.
I think I actually just confused you with what I was thinking too,
because I just watched bill special.
I didn't remember that part,
but that the Tracy Morgan thing with Tracy Morgan got in trouble for saying that
if his son was gay,
he would stab them.
Obviously that's a horrible thing.
But he also said that he would eat a mile of shit to get to beyonce is booty
like that's the part of in my act like come on.
He says ridiculous shit that's not actually true.
And he's saying it in a medium and entertainment medium where if you watch a
movie,
okay,
and the transformers destroy these buildings and someone gets stomped,
guess what?
No one really got stomped.
No buildings really got destroyed.
Bob Marley didn't really shoot the sheriff,
you know,
that's the point of the,
the bit.
But this,
this idea that everything is supposed to be homogenized and calm down and come
on,
this is ridiculous.
Yeah.
I think we all want to society right where we all have our worth based on what
we do and like we,
we respect each other,
but not so much where there is no fun.
Exactly.
There's no fun left.
And part of the fun is saying Shit that you look like you're you,
you say shit.
That is ridiculous.
That is fun to say because you know that you don't mean it and you assume that
your friends know you don't mean it as well and that's part of the subtle nuance
of fucking around with your friends and the problem with trying to do that in
public is that people will latch onto that.
They'll take it,
they'll take it as a quote,
they'll put it in quotes and they'll pretend that this is an actual statement
and this is how you actually believe and feel,
and then they'll just write a blog about it.
They'll write a tumblr blog and get super upset about it and that's what you're
talking about.
Like don't you say retard someone's gonna write this huge blog,
but he hate people.
That's not what's going on.
It's not what's going on and in pretending what you're doing is you're focusing
on something that's not really that important and you're pretending it is and
there's a lot of real issues in the world,
right?
You could be focusing your attention on instead of someone saying retard or
someone saying,
your mom's going to have a giant black robot fucked all that.
That throws Dick all day,
all day,
and she's going to kick your dad out of the house.
You fat fucking loser.
You'd get Outta here.
Arnold's gonna fuck me now.
Yeah,
but that's not real.
I don't.
We don't really mean that,
but we live in this time where anybody has a voice.
Anybody can just write something on twitter or write something on facebook or
Tumblr and I think that's good.
I think it's good,
but right now there's a sort of balancing out stage where people are still
freaking out about these things and they're just like this,
this sort of new understanding of this ability,
this new understanding of this ability to freak out about that.
Yeah,
but I think a lot of people don't realize the power.
I mean,
the main,
the main thing that you see specifically with celebrities and sometimes they'll,
they'll say something just offhand and then it'll just,
it we will get warped and then other people feeling like they're so small that
they can just literally say anything,
anything like the most vile crap ever because it's the internet and they're
like.
And it's fun.
Yeah.
That is a thing that people do.
Like Jonah Hill,
when he called some reporter,
he called someone a faggot.
It was like the guy that was like,
yeah,
he was like harassing him,
not alone.
Yeah.
And then he,
uh,
he sort of apologized for it and it became like a big and became the word he
used became more important than someone like following him around and sticking a
camera in his face,
violating his,
his personal freedom or violating his privacy,
you know,
it became all about a word,
that.
And that's unfortunate.
It's like he chose the wrong word,
you know,
if he said,
get out of here,
you fucking parasite.
Then it would have been more about the behavior of the person falling him with a
camera that it would have been about him reacting to that person with
well and the whole,
the whole.
That whole story ended up being.
Yes,
specifically about the word and then his apology for it.
Which it's always interesting to see famous people go on like a tonight show or
something like that to apologize.
Tie On.
Yeah.
And you're just like,
we know that this is like,
it's a setup moment.
Right?
And it's like you giving this statement and it's just,
it's,
it's so weird.
Yeah.
It's sad.
But it is,
but you know,
people are scared.
They're scared of a PR thing,
but that's also a thing that I understand.
Like I never had to grow up worried that I was going to beat.
I get beat up because of my sexual orientation that no one was ever going to
like tie me to a fence and beat me to death.
So when,
when I think a lot of people take it to the next level when they talk about
things like where I like offhand mention white privilege because I didn't have
to go through that.
I do get annoyed by the people on the extreme end of the argument that act like
I can't have an opinion on anything because of the color of my skin and my and
my and my and my sexual orientation or any of these things.
But it's,
I don't know,
I get it.
It's,
it's the world is gray man.
I get it.
It is very gray.
It is.
It's like,
you know,
would you use the term like,
if,
if I said shut up bitch,
would you use that?
If you are around a woman who had just been called a bitch,
you know,
if someone had just yelled at you stupid bitch at a woman,
which is the worst way you could use that term.
Would I still say to Barnes,
bitch,
get the fuck out of here.
Then you would be more sensitive about.
He'd be like,
well I can't.
We've got to get away from this chicken,
then I'll call you a bitch,
you know,
or I'll use the term bitch about myself,
I'll say,
you know,
I'll do something stupid.
I'll be like,
bitch,
do you even know how to fucking turn your car?
You know what I mean?
I'll,
I'll use it at me as well as I'll use it at someone else.
But would I do that if somebody had just been called it in a very hateful way?
No,
but that's where it gets weird.
That's where it gets gray,
you know,
like that's why the word faggot is just like,
it's just too complicated because even though the intent is what's important
when you're dealing with words like in the intent is not homosexual slur.
Your friend is a homosexual and you're making no.
It's like he's a wimp or he's.
And then you go,
well,
okay,
what does that mean?
Then?
Does that mean that gay men are wimps?
Well,
no,
that's not what you mean.
Well,
you probably need to come up with a better word.
It's like the word.
The problem with that word is that it's ineffective and conveying the actual
thought because it's too easily,
it's too easily connected to gay slurs or two things that have incredibly
negative connotations or are just their prejudice terms,
so you have to kind of let them go and come up with something else.
Yeah,
I leave it alone.
If it's those two words,
I say,
oh no,
those groups can talk about it and Louis Ck can talk about it and that's it.
I just stay away.
I go,
nope,
nope.
Not going to say it.
Those two groups.
Yeah.
That's the thing about gay people are allowed to use the f word.
They could say it,
they call each other fags,
but if I was,
oh man,
if I was black I would just use that word to all my white friends just because
some like some will get excited,
but others would just be like,
okay,
I'm going to leave this situation right now.
I know.
It's funny,
man.
It's funny.
It's
languages is an incredible thing.
I mean there's so much.
There's so much subtlety,
there's so much.
There's so many different ways you can say a sentence and have different
meanings,
you know,
and people are really sensitive about that today more than ever because we can
analyze things in a way and then communicate our analysis,
communicate our,
you know,
our interpretation of how you're speaking and communicate that.
And all you have to do is say something like if you say something fucked up and
someone takes it completely out of context,
you put it on twitter or facebook,
whatever you like,
you,
you know,
that sort of click baity in a lot of ways.
But it also a lot of ways like you did say that word,
you know,
you did say it in that term,
but it's not in the greater context of the conversation that you're having,
you know,
and that's what's lost in the flat medium of print.
That two dimensional medium of taking something in quotes and putting it in
print and that sort of the point that I was trying to make in my comedy central
special.
And that's,
you know,
that's something that's being lost today when people were just looking for
things to be upset about.
Right.
I don't know,
I,
I feel like I am constantly dodging stuff like that.
Just because someone said you can't say thug anymore.
I was quote,
I was quoting someone and I said ratchet.
And I liked and I like,
yeah.
And I,
and I was like,
oh whoa.
I was like,
oh,
she ratchet.
And that's when I,
when I say like the tumbler posts of like 200,000,
there was a tumblr post,
I think it has like a $100,000 that I used a aggressive racialized language.
And I was like,
wait,
what?
No,
what's wrong with ratchet?
I don't know.
It's,
you can't say ratchet.
It speaks down to
ratchet is like a tool in reference to a person,
you know,
that's like an earth.
Oh,
I don't know that.
Yeah,
like,
like that girl,
look at her shoes,
they're so ratchet or that girl is ratchet,
meaning like she is like,
like what would it be?
Like trashy.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
but I also can't keep up with stuff.
I think that's when I realized I'm getting old where I'm just like,
I see new words and I'm like,
I'm not going to care.
Like I saw there was,
is it pronounced here?
I don't even know if it's an inappropriate word,
but like thought it's like t h o,
t,
and I think it just means like,
whoa.
Right.
And I'm just like,
why?
Wait,
hold on,
hold on.
I need a new word that's bigger.
I am so out of the loop.
God,
I'm getting old.
So ratchet is what,
like trashy,
trashy,
like,
like she's so ratchet.
Hold the neck.
Can you do that again?
She's so rad.
I mean I did a 25 year old Latina.
That's the only reason I go.
Okay.
And so ratchet is bad.
You get in trouble for saying ratchet.
I didn't think I would,
I didn't.
I was quoting it and then uh,
yeah.
And then it just.
But that's the thing is people just take the sentence,
put it in quotes.
As we were doing this conversation,
someone actually responded exactly the way I was mocking.
This is on twitter in quotes.
That bitch should just shut the fuck up.
She's lucky you feed her an exact quote,
all caps from Joe Rogan.
Alyssa,
you fucking dummy.
We're talking about robots.
We're talking about robot fuck dolls.
Fake scenarios,
and by the way dummy,
I also said that in the term of the woman mocking the man and kicking him out,
which you conveniently decided not to quote.
See,
this is what I'm saying.
If women were to just get fucked,
they wouldn't be feminist in quotes.
Literally a thing Joe Rogan just said,
did I say that
you should go.
You should go through and see how long that person has been quoting you.
Did I say if women were to just get fucked,
they wouldn't be feminist.
That I say that,
look,
this is hilarious.
This philly d interviews should just be called the Joe Rogan sexist,
our this.
This gal must be a wonderful person to hang out with.
She's not oversensitive at all.
Oh,
here's another thing.
She wrote dear men of the universe in all caps.
In the grand scheme of things,
your Dick is so insignificant.
You're right.
Yeah,
that's true.
You have to tell everybody that though.
Why would you want to diminish a man by saying that in the greater scheme of the
thing?
Oh yeah.
The greater scheme of things,
your fucking ears are insignificant.
How about that?
Your nose is insignificant to.
Who cares if you smell farts in the greater scheme of the universe?
God,
this is exactly what we were talking about.
It's amazing when you talk about something,
you mock it and then someone misconstrues.
It's so badly that they literally become what you're mocking.
It's,
but it's.
It's amazing to me because I usually have to wait at least like for the video to
post,
so I love that it's happening in real time for you.
Yeah,
that's.
Well,
that's the beauty of it
being on ustream.
It's hilarious.
People are looking to be upset.
I mean,
we are in a strange time now.
We're a hundred Pakistani.
Kids were murdered the other day.
We have what's going on in Ferguson where there's constant rioting.
We have all this crazy shit that's every fucking day.
There's some new video of a cop beating the fuck out of somebody.
We have horrific injustice all over the world and people are getting upset about
a conversation
involving robot fuck towels.
You know,
sexism,
a real problem.
No Man would ever freak out that much about a woman talking about robot.
Fuck men,
and that is true.
If they would,
they.
They need to give up their men colored cars.
They're bitches.
I said,
picture,
I'm just going to the rest of this entire podcast.
I'm just going to be looking at your twitter.
Don't do it,
dude.
Don't do it
sick.
It's toxic.
It's filled with toxic masculinity at twitter.
Men's rights associations bother me way more than feminism tell.
I'll tell you that right now.
I think that's more ridiculous because men's rights,
I think the only time it's valid at all is involving divorce and children.
That's it.
Okay.
Divorce and custody.
Women's rights,
like women are way more,
way more diminished by society.
Way more marginalized by culture than men are.
It's like when you have a men's rights association,
like really like how much more do you need to control?
Like men make way more money.
They,
they,
they're in the positions of power,
like as far as like government,
they're way more represented when it comes to like ceos when it comes to like
head of industry.
They're way more represented like men's rights really.
Like what,
what,
what rights are we missing?
The only ones there like divorce loss,
but I mean that's it.
That's an example,
a perfect example of the extremes of both sides,
right?
Because it's something that comes from a really valid discussion from,
from like I,
it's not like when I say feminist,
I think of people that talk about equality,
but then there's this whole other level,
right?
That goes almost into,
into hating and attacking a giant group rather than the bad parts of men are the
bad groups of men and so then he just have all these people in the middle going,
ah,
shit.
Yeah.
I don't want to talk.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
It's like when you don't want to be.
I didn't even know what an MRA was.
Somebody called me an Mra on twitter.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Was that a meal replacement or something like that.
I didn't know what an MRI was,
so I had to google it and I'm like men's,
but then I thought about it like,
wait a minute,
a men's rights advocate as a bad thing.
Like someone who is a feminist was mocking me for being an Mra and I'm like,
oh,
that seems kind of fucked.
Like you're you.
You were specifically identifying on your twitter handle.
You look at their page,
feminist,
Hashtag feminist.
You are identifying with support for the female gender,
but you're mocking someone by using this as a pejorative,
like using men's rights advocate as a negative statement.
Right.
That's kind of hilarious thing.
Seems quite hypocritical.
The thing you have to be scared of though,
right?
There are so many just troll accounts that are meant to stir up the conversation
and like that's when I'm like reporting on stuff and I'm taking stuff from,
from the Internet and twitter.
It's so hard to tell because some of the people that are crazy,
crazy,
silly people say the same stuff as the trolls.
I don't know.
Are you being serious?
Well,
it's also.
It's funny because a lot of people that do it,
they do it just to get everybody freaked out and then people who are like
serious about it,
start taking them and using them as an example.
I go,
yeah,
he's right and like,
no,
and we're not right.
We're fucking around here.
Like there's a lot of people online that are trolls,
meaning that they literally are just for sport,
trying to rile folks up there just for sport.
They're trying to push buttons and get people route and that's another new
reality that we're faced with with the Internet,
like youtube comments,
how youtube comments are just literally designed to fuck with Philip DEFRANCO's
head.
Oh Man.
How many times I've seen your comments.
I've had to go.
I think I made something this week where I was just like,
I know that 80 percent of the people that watch this do not leave comments or
anything.
Just say what's up because everyone assumes the community is all awesome.
Twenty percent suck like 20 percent of the worst people in the world and all it
takes is 200.
Have some people that agree with something and some people that just want to
fuck with me to get like that stupid ass comment on the front,
on the front page,
at the top comment and I just see it and I'm like I don't,
I don't want to do this anymore because I fucking hate you.
I hate you so much.
And then and then and then people that don't know it's,
it's.
But at the end of the day you realize that it doesn't fucking matter at all,
but it's amazing that a very small number like say if your videos,
like some of your videos have like more than a million hits,
right?
Yeah.
Some,
I think these days that they average around half a mil.
Okay.
So think about that.
That's fine.
Hundred thousand fucking hits.
I don't know how many people that is because I'm sure some of them watch it more
than once,
but let's say it's 300,000 people.
All it takes is 10 unbelievable Douche bags to get on that comment section and
just start pounding.
He,
uh,
Nah.
And then you have this fuck fest,
this clusterfuck in your comments.
Yeah.
It's the best is when there are political statements on videos that shouldn't,
like,
like it's like,
uh,
what was it the,
the one where they were dumping water on it with the ASL challenge,
right?
Just like you would look and then it would be like some huge commentary about
how Obama was a communist and you're just like,
why do I hope that was like a copy paste and you didn't see this video and
you're like,
I'm inspired and just start fucking type in Obama's.
Yeah,
communism,
Marxism moments in those terms that people love to toss around.
You know,
it's uh,
we,
we live in amazing times in so many ways,
but also the,
the ability to reach people.
So it's.
So,
it's,
so,
it's so everyone is so accessible.
It's,
it's magical in a way that it's exposing all these weird aspects,
human interaction and human behavior in a way that's never happened before
because you're not actually talking to someone,
you're not in front of them.
Like if you said something and someone responded to it and said,
well,
you know,
I think that's offensive and you'd be like,
I'm not really Siri.
I'm kind of fucking around,
but you know,
I see what you're saying.
I see.
Like you could see like if somebody's really meant it,
yeah,
that would be offensive,
but you know,
the way to be funny is to actually goofed around and then you would have a
conversation with them and you probably come to some sort of an understanding,
but that's what people do.
You,
you say something,
I say something,
but when someone wants to write something about you,
whether it's a tumbler blog or something along those lines,
they're not interacting with you.
They're just spewing,
you know all around.
Yeah.
And they're,
they're spewing out these words and they're having this reaction where that
would be a completely different reaction if they actually talk to you.
You know,
and in that way it's an unbelievably ineffective way of communicating.
It's very self indulgent like to,
to,
to go off on Tumbler rants or twitter rants.
Like it's a very self indulgent in that way.
Oh definitely.
But whenever I look at that or anything in life,
I kind of wonder like does the good outweigh the bad?
And I think 100 percent it does,
like there's way more good.
Oh yeah.
Most certainly.
Yeah.
I mean the band is kind of funny,
you know there's,
there's certainly bad in terms of harassment,
harassment aspect is this,
that's the creepiest scariest because
especially when it comes to some of the evil fucking violent death threats and
shit that some people and almost most of it teams to go towards women and it's
just these,
there's a lot of men out there that are just not,
they're not deemed attractive to women.
They're not there,
they're not desirable by women and they've lived their life in this really
resentful state.
This like this painful state.
Like if you're a guy and you're going through life and you're constantly being
rejected and you're looking at some high school jock,
quarterback type dude,
it gets all the girls and you just fucking fuming inside.
You're angry and and you,
you know,
you live your life like this and then you have this outlet of expressing
yourself and then you see some woman and for whatever reason you've developed
this.
I know guys because of the fact that they've been rejected by women for so long.
They associate women with pain because they associate women with rejecting them
or with hating them and they get angry and they lash out.
You know,
they want,
they want that woman to feel a part of what they felt their whole life.
That's.
See,
that's fucking terrifying.
There was,
there was that,
there was that kid that shot up all those people at that,
a college party.
I think it was like earlier in the year or late last year,
and he had the,
like the youtube video is where he was talking about he was going to make women
pay Santa Barbara,
right?
Yeah.
The number of that
were like,
yeah,
it's women's fault.
That's what.
That's.
Well,
that's the men's rights guys in the pickup artist guys,
there was a lot of these pickup artists guys were saying like,
if these women weren't so stuck up and if they weren't so prudish,
like this guy would have gotten laid and this would've never happened.
Like that's crazy.
That's crazy.
You're dealing with a mental health issue for sure.
One hundred percent.
Like to blame this in some way on,
you know,
that this could have been cured with promiscuity.
Fucking bizarre.
Like that level of victim blaming.
That's what blows my mind.
Yes.
That blows my mind.
Yeah,
that's fucking crazy.
That's just.
I mean that's just insane.
And that's also,
that's also like being around too many likeminded psychos.
Like there's those groups they get together and they,
they like sort of like reaffirm each other's ridiculous notions and then they
feed off of each other and then they start attacking,
you know,
and then they start making those little egg fake twitter councils toss away
accounts and just talking mad shit to people.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think in the future you're not gonna be able to do that.
I think one of the things that's a problem with things like twitter is that you
can be anonymous,
you know?
Do you think that being anonymous is completely bad?
No,
because I mean because I think it's gray.
I mean,
I,
I think it is great.
Rather,
I don't think it's black and white.
Sometimes.
I think you can express yourself in an anonymous way honestly.
Whereas if it was your own name,
like if you wanted a tweet something about a movie and you're like,
man,
I don't want these people to be mad at me,
but this was the most fucking pedestrian piece of shit film I've ever seen in my
life.
Holy fucking.
How did this guy ever get a job?
Who fucking wrote this?
You're like,
I don't want to do that.
But that's how you really feel.
Yeah,
it's.
But that's the thing,
right?
So being anonymous,
you can go and you can go,
hey joe Rogan,
fuck yourself.
But you can also,
um,
get the word out slash criticized.
Maybe like a really bad professor.
You can,
um,
you can get something out about someone without the real life ramifications if
you,
if you did something else.
So that's.
And that's one of those things where I think that being an honest on the
internet overall,
I think the good outweighs the bad at this point.
Yeah.
I think the good outweighs the bad as well.
I think essentially,
like I said about youtube comments,
like you could have 10 people in 500,000 that attack your comments section and
ruin the whole fucking thing easily,
you know,
especially if they continue to post and continue to do it and that's,
overall 500,000 people are watching it or whatever and you know,
10 get upset,
it balances out.
The information is not changing.
Your video is not changing,
you know,
and if you get a certain amount of negative responses on twitter or a certain
amount of people that get angry at you,
ultimately the,
the unique ability to express herself that we experienced today is way more
positive than
it is negative.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
I mean,
over the course of doing the show because there's so much valid conversation and
we also banned the hell out of trolls.
I'm like,
we've had,
I feel like good conversations about capital punishment,
you know,
like my opinion has constantly changed on whether we should have that.
Like that should be a thing.
And I mean we talked about it on the show today.
That was the other one.
The uh,
there's a 14 year old kid are like 70 years ago he was convicted of murder in
South Carolina and they killed him like he was,
he was a 14 year old boy.
Had to put them on a,
uh,
on a phone book so they could electrocute him.
And,
and then you look at the numbers.
We,
I think it was,
we killed the,
the smallest number of people in 20 years.
We sentenced the smallest number of people to death this year.
Um,
and I don't know,
it's,
it's a good conversation most of the time.
Yeah.
As a father,
one of the things that you realize,
one of the things that's happened to me is that I've become way more kind and
way more forgiving of people's circumstances and behavior because I,
first of all,
I really Sam Harris,
who was on the podcast and he started talking to me about determinism and he was
talking about the idea of free will and determinism determinism,
the idea of your life experiences,
your genetics,
everything that you've gone through in your life is essentially what makes
Philip to Franco in 2014 on December.
Whatever the fuck the day is.
You know what I mean like that.
That is who you are and you.
This idea of free will becomes very cloudy because essentially you are this huge
accumulation of experiences and genetics and all these different things.
Well,
when you become a parent,
at least I've the way I've experienced,
I look at people very differently now because I don't look,
oh,
there's that guy is a fuck up.
Oh,
this guy's a loser.
I don't look at it that way.
I look at it like that was a baby.
Okay.
That was a baby that was raised in some probably unbelievably abusive
environment and they became this complete fucking idiot and 30,
right,
you know,
and most likely a large majority of how they became that person is not because
of their own actions.
It's because of the way they were raised and because of the circumstances that
they found themselves in just completely by chance.
And I look at serial killers that way.
Now I look at,
I look at,
you know,
negative people,
male and female in that way.
I just think a lot of what we're dealing with in our culture is people that
they,
they've been raised in an insanely shitty way by people didn't know what the
fuck they were doing.
They've had a bunch of horrible things happen to them.
They had bad circumstances and this is the result of that.
But at what point do you just,
is that,
is that a cop out and you don't hold people accountable for their actions?
That's the big question there was,
there was the,
the young was like,
I feel like he was 16 from a really,
really rich family in Texas.
And uh,
he and a bunch of guys that were under age,
they got,
they took a dad's car and got really,
really drunk,
drove a,
ended up killing a bunch of people and he ended up,
I think not doing any time in jail because they argued that because he was from
a rich family,
uh,
that,
that he didn't understand consequences for actions.
Like that's,
that's crazy.
That's,
I think you have to.
What's the point of rules?
If we go,
he's had too easy of a life or he's had too hard of a life.
I think that you can make changes.
Like don't don't put people that smoke weed in prison.
But,
but what about these violent criminals?
There's also a problem in that when human beings get to a certain point,
is there a way you can fix them?
Oh,
like a guy like a Ted Bundy,
right?
You can't fix that guy.
Like when they reach a certain point,
like you have to remove them from society.
You got to kill him.
He's deriving pleasure at a killing women.
What are we going to fix him?
And then trust that we can release them out in the public and he's not going to
go kill a bunch of more women.
No,
you can't.
You can't.
There's a certain point of no return where human beings reach and it always that
that point of no return always involves victimizing other people as soon as the
they hurt people or kill.
Okay.
Without death or violence.
Bernie maydoff,
okay,
how much money can you steal?
How many lives can you ruin?
How many financial futures can you destroy?
And we still let you go back into society and be a free person.
I mean,
there is also the question of in America,
I think the thought of rehabilitation is not there,
at least with our prison systems.
I don't know if it's because it's,
it's a moneymaker or it's just we just want what we consider monsters away from
us,
but don't really rehabilitate.
No,
we don't do anything with the mind.
Right?
I mean,
it's not like we take these people and we give them Mtma.
We put them on Iowasca retreats.
We try to connect them to their spiritual mother spirit.
You know,
we wouldn't know.
We put them in a jail cell and surround them with fucking psychos and then leave
them there for 10 years and hope they get better because they feel bad that they
had to live in this shitty circumstances for 10 years.
That doesn't fix anybody,
right?
Then you jump,
So the whole point of like when I cover things as jumping to the other side,
the other side would then argue,
what are you going to fucking caudal murderers?
Are you going to coddle pedophiles?
Are you going to,
are you going to punish people?
Because I think as Americans,
for the most part,
we think of prison as punishment.
You fucked up,
we're gonna fuck you up rather than you messed up.
We want you to be a member of society that is productive.
So here are classes and here's how you can learn and hear his therapy.
And once again I'm in A.
I'm in the gray area because there's like the fucking kid that,
that bombed the Boston bombing.
Like kill that kid.
That's mindset,
right?
And,
and it's these,
it's these mass outliers,
right?
These outlier situations that ended up changing my mind on when the Norway
shooter happened,
you know,
it's like you go,
how did that,
they don't kill that guy,
you know?
And so that's,
it's,
it's me constantly dealing with it myself and talking to the people that aren't
assholes online and trying to formulate it and evolve my opinion on it.
Yeah.
And I think also with really complex situations,
there is no black and white.
There's no right and wrong and yeah,
we kind of have to punish people when they do horrible things.
But again,
as a parent,
as a person who's watching human beings develop,
I'm realizing that a lot of the problem that we have in our culture is that some
kids don't get a chance.
They just don't.
They,
they,
they're,
they're in bad situations from the jump and they are the product of their
environment and some of them make it through horrible,
horrible neighborhoods,
bad situations.
They become stronger and better and have more character because of it.
But we shouldn't expect that.
We shouldn't force them to,
you know,
to be as good as the best people in their neighborhood.
Like everybody's circumstances very different and I always say,
this is the way I've been thinking lately.
If you lived someone's life,
you would be that person.
You know you,
you would be,
you know,
fill in the blanks,
ray rice,
you know,
if you,
if you live that guy's life and found yourself in that elevator with your
girlfriend and punched her in the face,
you're,
you're him.
You were that guy that is possible to become.
That person should be punished him abso-fucking-lutely,
but should we also recognize that you become a god that's willing to hit a
person or hit a woman?
You become a that through a lot of different variables through the way you were
raised,
the type of people that you communicated with,
the type of relationship you're in.
She is the wife hit him.
You know,
like they're hitting each other.
They do that.
There's obviously there is some sort of a abusive physical relationship.
You know,
I,
I'm pretty sure you're not that kind of a guy.
I'm definitely not that kind of a guy,
but is it because you didn't grow up that way if you grew up around a mom and
dad that beat the shit out of you and your dad beat the shit out of your mom and
you beat the shit out of your girlfriends and they beat the shit out of you.
You're throwing shoes at each other and duck and plates.
Then you be that fucking person I think maybe be
right because like my mom was nightmare growing up.
Like she's,
she's done that thing where as they get older,
like she,
she became a nurse and she's like taking care of people now.
But like she beat the fuck out of me sometimes.
Like just for no reason,
like for no reason.
It was like a bad day.
Yeah.
And it's not like it happened all the time.
Right?
It's not,
it's not the worst situation that's ever happened.
When I was growing up.
My,
my dad would use me to help steal stuff from like Walmart so that we can bring
it back and we could get money like,
so I didn't come from this place where was just like,
everything's easy and everyone's on that open up,
but I also don't do that now that I'm an adult because I think I saw those
things and then I looked outside and I was like,
oh,
that's fucked up.
You don't do that.
Like,
I'm never going to hit my wife.
I don't want my kid,
you know?
Like I said,
never hit my wife,
but I don't want to hit my.
Well,
my dad's little motherfucker gets crazy.
My Dad slapped me one time.
I was like six years old and I said,
fuck you.
And he slapped me once.
I'll never said it again.
I like how you said it in a six year old tone.
Oh Man,
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for him to say fuck you.
And I hate you.
Ooh.
Those were mean.
That wasn't mean words,
but you know,
it's your responsibility to go,
no,
you don't relax.
My Dad,
when my dad would just,
he would annoy me,
he would just say,
I ate you.
He's like,
you ate me,
and as six year old me just furious.
Angry.
Yeah.
My six year old gets mad if she,
if she pouts and starts whining about things.
If I go,
oh,
someone whining,
she'll freak out.
I mean,
it could be about nothing,
you know?
Yeah.
She's a little human being.
That's the thing about human beings.
I mean,
there they are this just bundle of potential and there's all these events and
variables that happen in your life that create who you are.
And I think that most human beings that raise children really don't know what
they're getting into when they started off and hopefully along the way they
develop a better person than they were.
You know,
that they do a better job of parenting based on the experiences that they've had
with their parents and the mistakes that they're aware that their parents made
and hopefully we learn,
but we're still just learning the effects of behavior and what it's like when
you raise.
Kids were still learning that we're still going over that and a lot of people
are terrible at.
I watched some fucking unit yell at her kid and pull him by the arm.
It's screaming that he's going to beat the tar out of him and I'm like,
Oh fuck man,
I'm watching some kid be raised by a moron,
you know,
and he's going to have to unlearn all this shit.
This more is teaching them.
And that's,
you know,
in some extreme situations like extreme abuse and extreme neglect and extreme
sexual abuse and violence,
you know,
you're going to develop a horrible person that's dealt with these variables
their whole life.
This is who they are,
you know,
this is,
this is the,
there are the product of all the things that have happened to them and how
they've processed those things.
But at the end of the day,
do you want that end product next to your kid?
No.
See,
but that's the thing is like,
I wonder how that's fixable.
I really don't.
I don't know if there's a way to reset the mind and some sort of a functional
way and it may be some sort of a psychedelic thing or it may be something that
has to do with neuroscience in the future with a.
They find out the issues of the human brain and they can literally reprogram the
mind and some sort of way and get them in in some unforeseen future technology,
some way to understand like why they've become this person,
why they are abusive,
why they are self destructive.
Maybe someone who's a drug addict who hates themselves.
You find out,
oh,
you really hate yourself because your mother hated you.
You know,
this is what it is.
Like you have this horrible reaction to being raised by this awful person and we
found the core of it like,
like you have an electrical problem.
Oh,
well here it is.
We found the wire has a slice in it.
It's getting,
you know,
the water's getting in.
It's shorting out.
We'll just fix that wire.
I mean,
if people.
If we can get to that point at some,
we can fix a lot of the problems in society.
Right,
but then who's to.
Who's to say what's right and wrong at that point?
Who's to say that you're broken.
You're not like,
where is that?
You do.
You take out the human,
essentially you're taking out the human,
right?
Because it's.
I mean at the end we kind of our wires but kind not wires.
Well then it comes back to the alien,
right?
Always.
That's the alien.
Sexless muscle lists.
Speechless.
You don't know if that dude,
if that alien,
it beats his wife.
You don't know he could.
They beat anything.
They're so skinny.
I think that get away with it.
Wife kick his ass.
I had this guy on Zoltan Istvan who's a futurist and he's one of those trans
humanism proponents.
Okay.
And Fascinating Guy,
but one of the things that he said is that these people that have recently,
I don't know if you're aware of this technology,
that they've recently been able to transmit words across the Internet to someone
wearing a helmet like with no,
with no words spoken.
You,
you think a word and having this helmet on this,
this series of electrodes that attached to your head that somehow understand the
what part of your brain is firing up.
When you think of a word like hello,
right before it.
Hello?
Hello.
Registers in some sort of an area of your brain.
This person wears his helmet and they hear hello in their mind.
That's wild dam.
Yes,
and they hear it through the Internet.
Well,
he said that they believe that this technology over the next couple of decades
going to advance so fast and so strong that we are going to lose communication
like oral communication.
We're going to speak directly,
mind to mind from now on.
Well,
I wonder if,
because obviously it sounds like they have someone go,
okay,
think of apple 20 different times,
apple,
and then think of banana.
Is it that big of a difference?
Is it where are you gonna be able to get all the small intricacies or is it
going to be like,
this is anger.
Like,
ah,
I wonder if you have to like look at an apple and send me wonder how many things
are involved if like you have to see a visual apple and think the word apple so
that your mind knows this is like if you're visually sending that information as
well as sending the word to the mind.
Well saw a video
this morning of a guy that was like 40 years ago.
He lost both of his arms and he went to John Hopkins and they were testing this
new stuff on them and they put it on and they just said like think about moving
your hands.
And so we thought about rotating his hands out and they did like a full three
60.
He could move them a little.
Obviously the technology is really early on,
but the fact that he can think turn left and a bunch of Zeros and ones or
whatever gets thrown into this machine via his nerves and it happens.
It's amazing.
Like where are we going to be in 20 years?
Most of the video today of the guy with a two percent of arms,
we lost them in electrical is electrical,
so they called it like a freak electrical accident.
We're going to,
in 20 years from now,
we're going to have completely new limbs just like Luke skywalker did when darth
vader cut off his hand.
Remember that shit?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean that's it.
Those are.
Those are the things that are most exciting about three d printing,
like medical reasons.
That's huge.
Not me making a key chain.
They've already figured out how to three D print meniscus,
they've figured out a three d print knee meniscus with this is a special type.
It's essentially a scaffolding with a special type of protein in it and when
they inserted into the body,
the body replaces meniscus on the scaffolding and so like where they are now.
Like I've had meniscus scoped on one of my knees so I tore.
Some of it is really fucking painful.
They had a bucket handle tear,
which means it would lock,
it would like lock out and so they go in there and they scoop it out and they
cut it and they and you heal up and it works great now,
but it's not as effective because you lose some of the cushioning between your
joints.
Well,
what they're going to be able to do now is create with three d printing this
artificial scaffolding for the meniscus with these proteins in it,
and you're going to have a 100 percent new meniscus.
It's going to grow back in place,
which is a life changing thing.
What is this?
Oh yeah.
We posted this to dog can walk again.
Thanks to three d printing.
That was he walking?
It's got wheels.
It's the cuter version of what this,
what does he got?
What is that?
They printed out like these,
uh,
kind of like legs almost.
I can't play the video.
He's the dog blade runner.
That's cool.
Yeah,
I mean they're going to be able to do anything.
They're going to be able to make human beings like we were talking about the
artificial fuck robot,
people thinking to make that it's going to happen if people live to be a
thousand years from now,
if that's going to be real,
I'm going to be so sad that they're gonna make sex robots before they do.
Oregon's like,
you know,
that's gonna happen.
I don't think so.
I think Oregon will be first.
I think it organs would be first before they can figure out a way to be a whole
person.
Yeah.
I mean that's going to be amazing,
but it's always a weird thing because I have this,
uh,
I have this thing called,
pkd polycystic kidney disease.
It's a genetic thing,
but sometimes I look at it and I'm like,
this is,
this shouldn't be here.
Like I shouldn't pass this on anymore.
Been we as a society and as technology advances I get to live.
And what is it involved?
Like what cysts grow over time it'll really hit me.
I think around when I'm like 35,
40,
that's when I hit my dad.
I'm cis form on your kidney.
And it just essentially slowly squeezes it to death and so late term you need to
get a,
like you have to go on dialysis because their kidneys are failing and then uh,
and then you kinda just have to get on the donor list.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's,
it's rough stuff.
But I mean,
it hasn't affected me yet,
but it's like that thought that I sometimes have when I'm laying down at night
and just thinking of like infinity,
uh,
that I,
my specific cells,
my jeans shouldn't be passed on.
Right.
If you think of us advancing,
but then technology kind of brings me back along.
It's like,
no,
in like a hundred years we'll be able to make those kidneys again.
You're fine.
Well,
people,
you used to have diabetes,
we're dead,
right?
You know,
there was a death sentence and now it's not.
Now you get on insulin,
they figured out a way to change your diet and that's a huge issue as well.
Does that have anything to do with your diet?
With the kidneys is the right way to long it?
Yeah.
Oregon kind of like,
I have to make sure that I always drink a lot,
a ton of water and drinking should be problematic.
Right.
Is drinking alcohol.
I think that's more.
I think that's more of a liver.
Yeah.
I um,
for the most part it's just.
I mean,
I'm starting to think more about my health.
you guys were talking about like going up and down in weight.
Uh,
I dropped 35 pounds this year mainly because I just,
I don't wanna die.
I wanna I want to be able to.
Because also when,
when pkd hits me harder,
it's gonna be harder to exercise.
I have to like train myself essentially to just not eat like an asshole like I
normally do.
Right.
Wow.
That's intense.
Man.
Kidneys are a big one in mixed martial arts because guys cut weight a lot and so
a lot of them wind up getting kidney stones.
That's the worst thing.
Apparently it's a genetic thing.
Some people just don't ever get it,
but some people when they cut weight,
kidney stones become a huge issue and it has something to do with dehydration.
Dee Dee dee dehydration slash genetics.
Yeah,
I've had,
I've had one because I think there's like a 40 percent higher chance that if you
have it you will,
you'll get more kidney stones have.
You Don't have to pee it out.
Is that what happened?
Yeah.
So mine mine was a,
it wasn't so big that they had to like try and blast it.
Uh,
but they essentially,
I think that they gave me percocet and I was essentially in and out for three
days at home and at some point I paid it out.
I was just like,
I'm going to drug this one out.
I'm not doing this because I was like,
okay,
now maybe it's just I have back pain like first day,
the second day.
Oh,
went away third day.
it just moved,
like that's what it was.
The pain is just a different place and yeah,
that was the least fun thing I've experienced in my life,
man.
Being out of little rock and then imagine giving birth.
Imagine what women goes.
You did your actual
dose dose out twice crazy.
I thought I'd never want to.
And then I was just like,
no,
I have to.
Got To have to be there.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's beautiful in a way.
It's strange.
It's,
you know,
it's very oddly psychedelic because when that child was coming out of my wife's
body,
I was thinking to myself like,
wow,
this is what's happening right now.
All over the world and mass.
There are millions of babies coming out of a giant,
like simultaneously.
And I imagined seeing it on some massive screen,
like seeing a million windows,
like if you had a massive computer screen with a million windows open,
just babies being born and people dying,
just seeing if he's getting a destroyed.
I didn't think of it that way.
I thought of it the positive way.
So on the,
the,
the idea of this,
this giant super organism that's constantly expanding and contracting,
expanding and contracting.
And you know,
most of the time now expanding more than contracting.
When you find out that the population,
number of the world,
just like,
I believe like in the 19 fifties it was only 2 billion in the world,
something like that.
And now it's seven.
Right?
That's fucking nuts.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's weird.
Like less than 100 years and it's $5 billion plus.
Well that's what I'm saying.
Right?
So as stuff advances and people like me and people that were supposed to,
well not supposed to genetically would have died.
Right.
Technology is going to have to advanced for food and space faster because
otherwise we're just going to die,
but it's not going to have it.
What the court.
You say just eat corn.
Yeah.
What does that maybe to cast stella that eat corn if it's just corn left at the
end,
but I'm not supposed to.
Nineteen 50.
There was only 2 billion people in the world.
That was what it was.
That's crazy.
Blowing up.
Yeah,
it was 2 billion.
Five hundred and $66,000 or 550.
$6,000.
That's not.
And is it that.
I'm trying to think how much of that has the Internet.
Mostly porn.
Well now it's 7 billion.
I mean,
but this is,
this was the world in 1950.
It was so much smaller.
There was so many.
I mean,
how many people were in America in 1950?
What do we say?
US population.
Nineteen 50.
What did
you say?
Three.
Three something?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'd say what?
Maybe let's go with $3,150 million.
A hundred 50.
Half.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think.
I wonder what the United States.
You have the baby boom compared to other places,
you know,
1940.
It was only 131.
As soon as they start figuring out medicine,
that's where it all went downhill.
No child left behind.
I mean that's also how you invent shit,
Ya know,
you have to have surplus and you have to have leisure.
You have to have people that have the ability to sit in front of computers and
desks and figure things out.
And that's where you,
without agriculture,
without cities and without civilization,
you know,
you don't have any inventions.
So all of it comes out of our ability to relax.
You know,
we have the food,
we have a place where we can sleep.
Okay,
let's relax and let's work on other stuff instead of hunting and gathering all
the time.
Let's try to figure out how to make a wheel.
Oh,
I think we can figure out a way to have a controlled explosion that powers and
engine and that engine can get us on a road and we can get places that we can't
get to by walking.
Right.
Well,
so I would be interested.
So technology in general,
it's good.
We're all,
we're all going up at some point.
I mean I think it's very close with um,
with self driving cars and,
and just even computers in general,
like they're gonna be a lot of people that they don't have.
They're not gonna have a job anymore.
They're like their,
their place,
right.
If I think of my skill set,
I can be replaced for the most part by a computer.
Like you have all the people in the fast food industry.
I think like,
you know,
they've been going out saying they want $15 an hour in New York.
At the end of the day,
if you own that business,
technology isn't a place where all those front,
the people in the front,
you don't need you.
You just have like a kiosk.
No,
but isn't that the case?
Like always like if do we need blacksmiths to have jobs?
Right?
Should we play?
Well,
we without the horses,
what do I do?
Maybe you need to come up with a new thing to do,
but if we're going to run out of shit to do and then just go to twitter and like
give you shit with entire day.
Sure.
All those people that are running out of shit to do a probably if they found a
thing they enjoyed would have some other thing that they can do.
Right.
I just think it's kind of crazy to think of progress as taking away jobs.
Yeah.
And,
but that's the argument.
So many times the.
If you look at like the trucking industry,
if you look at,
I mean right now the big one is Uber,
right?
I mean that's not even automated cars.
That's just convenience and everyone's like,
no,
we can't.
This is,
we have something that's already established,
a track sheet community is upset and so and those guys,
I bet those guys are the guys that are sharing any terrible uber story.
Uber's everywhere.
Uber's worth $41,000,000,000 and none incredible right quick.
That happened.
There were two instances,
instances of something happening and everyone's like Uber's shit on in India,
right?
Yeah.
There was a,
there was,
there was a rape accusation there,
there was also.
And so I think it's good to those stories come out because it background checks
super important.
Obviously a huge.
Someone's driving you around in a metal box and then there was a,
I think there was also another one where a guy that had been convicted or
charged with a violent crime killed someone.
Wasn't there one where a guy like took someone somewhere and wouldn't let him
go,
like protect them to some abandoned warehouse or some shit or something that was
an American thing.
I don't know.
Took them to a parking lot or something.
Maybe you might be thinking of fake taxi as a fake tax.
Don't Google it.
It's okay.
No,
no.
Um,
but I also at the same time,
anytime I hear those stories,
I think of every drunk friend I have that's yelled at or done something wrong to
an uber driver.
And I'm like,
maybe it,
yeah,
there's a bunch of shit.
It's not the India situation,
but obviously like the,
the,
there was a,
uh,
words that turned into fists really with Uber Drivers.
Well,
yeah,
with the story.
I'm just like,
uh,
there've been those small instances,
but it's not widespread.
I think for me,
I don't care if the guy that owns uber's a huge asshole,
all I know is it's convenient.
Right.
And it's forcing the taxi companies to change where they come out with like
their versions,
which I still don't use,
but I think,
I think it just makes sense.
Like let's keep doing more and more and more.
Yeah.
I,
well they're very friendly,
like,
especially Uber in New York City,
I found them to be much more friendly than calves.
Calves are just like,
you know,
that you know,
that you need them.
They know you need them and sometimes they're shitheads a lot of times they're
friendly,
but the uber drivers were like across the board,
friendly almost because it's this new thing and they also want you to give them
stars,
you know,
they'll,
they'll want you to rate them and they,
if they were rated highly than people,
get excited about that person picking them up and then I'll also tip them as
well as you know,
the,
the money that they get from the little,
the application where your credit cards in there.
They get a percentage of that.
Right.
It's like something.
I forgot what the,
I forgot what the split is.
I know that
I knew a guy that was part of that watch my show that was an uber x driver and I
think they get a similar rate or something slightly different,
but those,
I think those weird me out a little more.
Uber X is weird.
Yeah,
that's a car that's like someone's just car.
Someone rolls up in a cube and then get in and I'm like,
I had a guy picked somebody up here in a Prius,
in a certain room or a volt was like a volt was a fake.
This is way better though,
is it?
Unfortunately my girlfriend uses lyft and I don't think that they have the same
quality control.
And as Uber this guy came in with windows.
What?
F 10 pickup trucks with the big pickup back in a,
in a cab.
You know,
like what construction workers she gets.
We both get in.
I'm like,
why did you call an uber or why didn't you call Uber?
I get in,
there's a shovel in the back of his truck.
The guy seemed like flustered that I was there because I think he just saw my
girlfriend's profile pic was corrupt.
So then he,
he fakes a phone call.
Jamie was watching me the whole time.
He fakes a phone call and starts yelling at somebody and we're just like,
what are we doing in this is not driving.
He's just sitting there.
I'm like,
like,
uh.
So we get out.
He's Jamie's outside taking photos.
Because he thinks that it looks something's not right,
and I'm like thinking my girlfriend wasn't.
If I wasn't with my girlfriend,
she would have got in this weird car with a shovel in the back and he,
you know what the fuck?
He's a gardener
really into plants.
Yeah.
Well,
so I mean with the,
with women I,
I'm one of the last week were drivers.
I had my friends,
once again,
we're super,
super drunk and they're asking all these questions.
I don't know if he was messing around,
but he was like,
no,
a good number of uber drivers if they're like attractive men are constantly
invited inside.
Like at the end.
Yeah.
And I was like,
that seems like a perk.
Yeah,
a good number of them.
Yeah.
Drunk chicks coming home from bars,
man,
there's a guy you might come in to smoke some weed,
you know,
Shit.
Probably.
Pow,
POW,
POW.
Aaa I think is doing it now because you really.
Well,
a lot of people do it to make money.
I mean,
you could do it on your own time,
you know,
you could have your own shifts in a way.
It's kind of cool if,
if they have real background checks,
I mean if they really make sure you have no mental health issues,
you know,
fucking sex Predator,
fill in the blank know and it's such a genius idea just because it's like you
don't really have to have that much infrastructure.
Yeah.
You know,
just to get things rolling.
Especially with the introduction a long time ago.
Uber X,
Uber X.
Yeah.
That's where it gets weird,
right?
They have spotify now where like on your phone you could sit there and control
the music that's in the car so you can put on whatever music you want.
Crazy.
Pretty soon it's gonna be rolling up the windows and turning on air conditioning
and.
Well,
how do you feel about these,
uh,
Google cars?
These self driving cars.
It's awesome.
That's fascinating.
Yeah,
I mean I think there was something recently where they,
they're not the best in the rain right now,
but it's still early tech.
Oh look,
they don't the breaking,
they don't think it's something with the way that it perceives like the outside
world,
a slippery traction things on those lines because they always ended up having
these,
these articles and stories where they talk about things like I don't think about
like uh,
people on bicycles,
you know,
things that don't look like cars and I don't know,
I mean it's baby steps.
It's not going to be there tomorrow,
but I think it's awesome.
I think you,
you,
you're talking about once again more people surviving because you were a car
accident.
If you can have some sort of system that can be thrown into an old car,
you know,
people.
I'm not saying make it mandatory because I like,
I love driving my car.
Like it gets me excited.
A bacardi drove a challenger.
Oh yeah.
You've seen the hellcat.
Yes.
Really?
It looks exciting.
It looks like 700 horsepower.
Wow.
That's not necessarily.
How much is it though?
It's not that expensive.
It's like $65,000.
That's 700 horsepower car with a warranty.
It's amazing and it's really comfortable to drive.
We drove around for a few days in Denver.
It's really nice.
Yeah,
I uh,
yeah.
Before that I had a,
it was like an rx eight.
It was like a Mazda rx eight and it's just like this little little tiny car.
And then I got into that and it's one Mercedes has this new s class,
the [inaudible],
another big luxury sedan that drives itself up to 30 miles.
An hour like stays in lanes,
makes turns,
it reads,
it reads speed,
limit signs and will follow the speed limits.
Dude,
it's fucking crazy.
That's awesome.
And it's,
it's good to about 30 miles an hour where you set this?
The sensors?
I don't,
I don't know all the tech but it breaks when cars are in front of you,
slows down when traffic slows down,
speeds up.
So like around town you were essentially could be like just,
you know,
hands in your pants and this thing's driving 30 miles an hour.
This fucking
crazy.
Where are you rolling?
Thirty miles an hour with your hands down your pants everywhere.
If I could.
Well,
especially because it has a screen,
it has these giant LCD screens,
these 2:12 inch lcd screens.
The speedometer is a 12 inch LCD screen.
All your gauges,
your gauge cluster is all an lcd screen and you're.
You're fucking nap screen.
Ian Edwards and I rented one when we were in DC.
Dude,
they are so slick and the all your navigation system is huge.
It's 12 inches enormous and you could watch movies on it.
The way it's set up,
only the pasture can see the movie like when the car is moving,
but when you're parked you can see it.
Say That's the thing that annoys me the most is when like my gps that's built in
treats me like a child and I can't answer that and anything in rides.
Yeah,
but BMW allows you to do it on the fly as you're driving.
I liked that you spin the wheel and you enter into it.
Mercedes is like a little more goofy.
The interface,
like the wheel,
the BMW we'll is very easy to use.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's the.
Yeah,
that's a sexy car.
It's a dope car and it's.
You're floating when you drive in that thing,
man,
I mean it just floats over.
Potholes and everything.
It's super comfortable inside,
but that technology is,
I mean this is like baby steps.
It's allowing you to essentially keep your hands off the wheel up to about 30
miles an hour.
They don't recommend you take your hands off the wheel,
but essentially it really does drive itself and there's some videos of guys
trying and working on it and it really does work.
That's so interesting.
But you have to have a clearly defined lines on the road because it goes by
cameras and the cameras interpret what it's seeing and it figures out how to
steer and drive.
It's like,
well,
if there's,
if that's already a thing,
right?
It's processors get faster and cameras can do it.
Go higher frames per second.
Like I wonder when that can go like 70.
It's going to happen.
It's a matter of time.
Well,
how fast can the Google cargo?
Uh,
I think it's 30,
so I think it's around the same range.
Oh really?
I didn't know it was that week.
Well,
not that we're getting on the highway with those because if you sound like the
newest one that doesn't have a steering wheel,
like it's just you saying that that's crazy.
Like good luck.
Yeah.
Because it seems like you should have a steering wheel.
Like it seems like it should be.
At least now it should be like just sort of some sort of an extra thing like not
mean what the fuck.
What if it breaks,
you know,
and you're driving.
No.
Ah,
and there's no steering wheel going straight towards the school.
It reads,
it reads a speed limit sign is like $200 or something like that.
Let's do this.
Oh,
I didn't even think of that.
Fake speed signs.
The newest hack.
Well you can hack things like I was talking about the screen in the car.
What I meant was you could drive 30 miles an hour and just beat off to porn as
you're driving because I used to have an infinity and I had this guy rick a
switch it out,
a DVD player and uh,
I had this guy rick a switched so that it thinks that the parking brake is on,
so it thinks you're in park,
so we just press the switch and you could watch movies while you're driving.
You remember that car?
Yeah,
I was watching Bruce Lee movies when I was on my way to the comedy store.
I didn't really watch them.
I paid attention to the road and responsible adults,
but I liked the fact that it was there.
And a cop actually pulled me over and he said,
uh,
yeah,
you can't,
you can't have that a plane while you drive.
I go,
dude,
I don't even know what's going on with this.
It's not supposed to do this.
Oh yeah.
Just ask.
Just being the backseat.
Shit's not working.
Sun.
The thing won't stop playing.
Bruce Lee movies,
man.
Most cops don't know shit about tech.
So you can get away with,
get away with lying to him about that.
I'm terrible with that.
Like as soon as I see a cop pulled me over,
I'm just like,
ah,
I'm not even gonna.
Try and talk my way out of this.
I'm terrified.
Yeah.
One thing I don't ever do is I don't ever allow a weed to get into my car inside
my car.
Yeah,
because you see it smells weeds.
The weird thing about weed is when you're smoking weed,
you don't smell it.
You're smoking it.
But people around you like,
God damn,
that's some fucking stinky weed.
And you're like,
I don't smell shit.
It's strange.
Like friends will come over and they'll stink of weed and they don't even know
they stink of which
stinks of weed.
He says,
yeah.
See that's something like talking to people and then hearing their stories where
they like bring stuff.
I'm like,
you're crazy.
You're a crazy person.
I don't care how easy it is.
It's easy to get.
Oh,
you crazy to travel with it.
You know.
That's what I'm saying is like when you're there,
you know,
like when I talked to people that are all about it,
they give me these 80 step plans and I'm like,
or you go a day without it.
That could be cool too.
It's not that big of a deal.
The man tired of the man tried to take away my.
We'd like if you want to,
if you want to talk about the TSA being like,
like bad.
Okay.
That's great.
Yes.
You know,
but fucking don't,
don't go over state lines with something illegal.
So stupid because in some places it's really illegal.
Like Texas,
if you get busted in Texas,
that is really fucking illegal.
That's something that's a little.
There have a little while.
You see Congress passed this new,
uh,
this new approach to medical marijuana there.
They're not attacking medical marijuana at all anymore.
They've quietly done this over the last few days.
There are no longer gonna prosecute states or anybody that's involved in medical
marijuana.
They're gonna allow states to do what they're doing,
which is great.
That's
weed is,
it ruins old episodes of cops.
Like that's something like when you see like [inaudible],
you see some people with like crack,
but then like you just see a guy that has like the smallest amount of just
probably like terrible weed and he's like,
you're gonna go to jail for a long time.
The
Zip tie his risk,
throwing them into a cage.
Yeah.
It's fucked man.
Yeah,
it is.
It is strange.
But Obama's passing these things until Jeb Bush gets in office,
then it all gets fucked that up.
You think that's what's going to be?
I'm worried,
man.
I think.
Well,
if Jeb Bush doesn't get no office,
Hillary Clinton will be president.
It'd be,
it'd be one of those two.
It'll be Jeb Bush or Hillary.
I'll take hillary over.
Jeb Bush.
Yeah.
I think it's time for a woman president still give her chicken chance to fuck
up.
You know?
So we really,
I think once hillary gets in and she does the exact same shit Obama did,
everybody's going to go,
hey,
I don't think the president really gets to say anything.
It's going to go through every possible thing and then it's gonna just go back.
Well,
remember what it was all bad bitches be used again as a word,
but Obama was before he got into office,
like the most progressive guy ever.
The most anti,
like his stance on whistle blowers supporting whistleblowers.
He backtracked on all that shit.
Just going to close down.
Guantanamo Bay never happened.
I mean it took forever to get out of Iraq and then still by saying we're out of
Iraq,
it's kind of bullshit because there's thousands of fucking troops still in Iraq.
You know?
Afghanistan is still going on.
Most of what they say never comes true once they get into office and I think
it's because they can't really do the things they want to do.
There's too much going on.
There's too many.
There's too many influences.
There's too much money.
There's too much power.
I think the president has way less power than we think.
Well,
it's always rough weather if there's a republican or a Democrat in the White
House.
Oh,
oh,
sorry.
Yeah.
Whether there's a student myself,
a Republican or Democrat in the White House,
like people forget about Congress.
Like what?
That it can be a huge obstacle or the reason that a president can do so much.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
It's huge.
And it's also the Republican versus Democrat fucking mudslinging that like
nobody wants to give an inch.
They're all just so this partisan ideology.
Whereas they just stick with the right wing and stick with the left wing and
they're all duking it out for control.
It's just so frustrating and it's like such a roadblock to any real progress.
Yeah.
It's,
I don't know,
it's A.
I covered the,
the rnc just because I got the opportunity and in and that was a weird thing
like the rnc and the DNC,
going to those events and just seeing how excited everyone is,
but how sensitive and like you say one thing and they'll jump down your throat
on either side.
They're on teams,
man versus the dolphins.
I mean that's really what it is.
And then meanwhile you have people that are like,
I'm libertarian,
and they're like,
that's great.
That's great.
Whatever.
And that was something that I looked at for awhile and when I would talk to just
anyone that was in office,
they were like,
you could go libertarian or you could just be a modified version of one of the
two parties.
And that's a weird thing.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I think until we realized that were being had across the board and that this is
all just a big charade that's being put on by corporations,
we're never going to figure it out.
We're never going to get past private prisons.
And I mean the supreme court giving corporations the ability to donate on
limited amounts of money towards candidates and those candidates obviously
support these corporations ideas once they get into office and allow them to
make money.
And a lot of times that money,
making that money is detrimental to the greater good mankind or the population
or just people in general were.
We're in a weird place.
And I think one of the things that we're seeing now though is transparency on a
level that we've never had before.
And ultimately,
I think that transparency and this distribution of information that we've been
talking about this,
this ability to access information,
it's going to make a really hard to hide all the evil shit you're doing.
Right?
I mean,
there's been stuff coming out and that's seeing that,
like whether someone says Patriot or whistle blower or like not terrorist,
but a little bit of a.
what's the word I'm thinking?
Insurgent.
No,
I'm just someone that turns on their own country having trader.
Huge.
Yeah.
I'm having a brain fart.
But just like the people that go,
yeah,
what we did was wrong,
but they had no right to put that,
put out that information and just seeing those arguments and like,
no,
right,
like the Chelsea manning argument or the uh,
the wikileaks Julian assange's argument.
Yeah.
I mean those people are in jail.
Those people did things that everybody thinks we're right.
I mean if everyone who's rational,
you look at what Chelsea manning the,
the life that she's had since she's been in jail,
you know,
locked up naked,
left in a cell cold with no clothes,
solitary confinement for years.
Literally.
I mean,
that's psychological torture,
I mean they're,
they're trying to break people and this is someone that just exposed illegal
activity and released information to this Julian assange character who now is
trapped in a fucking house in London,
can't leave.
He's in an embassy or he goes to jail,
but meanwhile,
if you had a vote,
a worldwide vote as to whether or not they did good things,
whether it's Edward Snowden,
same sort of situation.
If you have a worldwide vote,
what they did was that beneficial or was it negative for humanity and I will
guarantee you the vast majority would say it's beneficial,
right?
I mean,
the argument is that like you could potentially put us assets at risk if you
just throw out all this information,
but it is very much,
you know,
we did something wrong and you're,
you're putting us at risk because you're bringing it to light rather than going,
okay,
well let's bring this to light and let's not fucking do it again.
That'd be great.
Well,
it's certainly in some ways a gray area because intelligence operates under this
sort of a really strange blanket and the idea behind it is they're trying to
protect society from the evil people of the world and sometimes you got to break
a few eggs to make an Omelet,
but you know,
I mean,
Obama's whole stance going into office is completely contrary to what's going on
right now.
That whole whole hope and change website that he had,
they removed the whole piece on whistleblowers.
Oh Wow.
Because it was a bit.
Yeah,
it was a big story.
Big Story.
Yeah.
Because people like,
Hey,
remember this?
And then they like try,
just cut that out and deleted it and we delete it from the Internet.
Never pop up ever again.
We can slowly but surely remove it like Alyssa and tweets and
she's been deleting.
I'm sure.
Well listen,
I'm not mad at you.
Look,
I'd be mad at me too if I didn't know me.
So good kid.
But you know,
it's all right.
Listen,
we got to get out of here.
Okay.
We're out of time,
phil to Franco.
You're an awesome dude.
I appreciate you coming on,
man.
Thank you very much for having a lot of fun.
Folks,
please subscribe to his youtube channel because 3 million,
397,000 is just not enough.
Never and you need more and a really,
really great stuff though.
I really enjoy your videos and I enjoyed talking to you.
So we're in the neighborhood.
Males to the shimmer off of that for sure will be pals.
It's crazy.
Beautiful.
Philip de Franco.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'll be right back with Chris Harris,
one of the best automotive journalists in the world today.
See you soon.
In a couple minutes.
Bye.